I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Do not turn off this podcast. Keep listening to this.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这个终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。千万不要关掉这个播客。继续收听。
This is a good one. I know we're not breaking down an episode this week, but oh my gosh, this is so good. It is a delicious second drink. We have uncovered some fun stuff. This is a season four revisited and we are going to kick things off with an interview. We got to talk with Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer for seasons one through four. She is a badass woman. She is one of the original visionaries for the show.
这一集很棒。我知道我们这周不解析单集剧集，但天哪，这真的太棒了。它就像一杯美妙的饭后甜饮。我们挖掘到了一些有趣的内容。这是第四季重温，我们将以一段采访拉开序幕。我们采访了卡莉·贝内特，我们第一季到第四季的服装设计师。她是个女汉子。她是这部剧最初的远见者之一。
She helped create the show. You're going to hear all about it. She's amazing. Let's get to it. Let's get to it. Hey, hello, Carrie. Hi, Carrie. Welcome to Office, ladies.
她协助创作了这部剧。你们会听到所有关于这方面的故事。她太棒了。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。嘿，你好，卡莉。嗨，卡莉。欢迎来到办公室女士。
Oh, I'm so happy to be here. This is so fun. Carrie, I have been so excited for you to come on the podcast because I know that you have like literally the most awesome stuff to share. I know your story and I can't wait for everyone to hear it. Oh, good. It's fantastic and for the true Office fan, Carrie really helped shape the look of the show.
哦，我太高兴能来到这里了。这太有趣了。卡莉，我一直非常期待你来上这个播客，因为我知道你简直有最棒的东西可以分享。我知道你的故事，我等不及让所有人都听到了。哦，太好了。这太棒了，对于真正的《办公室》剧迷来说，卡莉确实塑造了这部剧的视觉风格。
In maybe the biggest way. Yeah. But let's start at the beginning. We always like to ask people, how did you get your job on the Office? I was designing the TV show Scrubs, so I was doing a lot of work with NBC at the time. It's all kind of foggy to me. Somehow I ended up on the pilot of the Office and it was in between, it was like on a hiatus from Scrubs.
也许是以最大的方式。是的。但让我们从头开始吧。我们总是喜欢问别人，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？当时我在设计电视剧《实习医生风云》，所以那时候我和全国广播公司（NBC）有很多合作。这一切对我都有些模糊。不知怎么的，我参与了《办公室》的试播集，那正好是在《实习医生风云》的间歇期，就像是一个档期空窗期。
I just squeezed it in. It was just a little pilot, 90% never go anywhere. That's right. You were like, it's a good summer job. Right. I'm on a break from my regular job, designing a whole TV show Scrubs, so I'll just do this as a little summer break gig. Right?
我只是硬挤出时间来做这个。这只是一部小试播集，90%的试播集都石沉大海。没错。你当时想，这是个不错的暑期工作。对吧。我从设计整部电视剧《实习医生风云》的正职工作中抽身出来，所以我就把这当成一个小小的暑假零工来做。对吧？
Well, you don't know. You don't like put too many eggs in that basket. It was actually a really long time before it went somewhere, I think, wasn't it? It was. A year maybe, I feel like. It was. Okay. So here's the story I'm dying for you to tell, Carrie, which is you agree to do the pilot
嗯，你可说不准。你不会把所有的鸡蛋都放在一个篮子里。事实上，过了相当长一段时间它才真正成型，对吧？确实如此。大概一年吧，我觉得。是的。好吧。卡莉，这是我极渴望你讲述的故事，那就是你同意为
for the Office and now you have to create the wardrobe design. What do you wear at a paper company in Scranton? Right. Well, research is the king of the whole deal and I never assume that I know what I'm talking about. I always try to go to the source and see something in real life because real life is always way more nuanced and amazing than anything you can think up in your head. It just is.
《办公室》制作试播集，现在你必须设计服装。在斯克兰顿的一家造纸公司，大家该穿什么？对吧？嗯，调研是整件事情的关键，我从不假设自己无所不知。我总是试图去寻找源头，在现实生活中亲眼看看，因为现实生活总是比你在脑海中构思的要细腻和精彩得多。事实就是如此。
I always find things that astound me and are the little seed that sets the fire off in me. Yeah. So how did you do that? How did you find the real life of this? Yeah. Well, so I was like, I've never worked in an office. I have no idea.
我总能发现让我大吃一惊的事物，它们就是点燃我心中热情的小火苗。是的。那你当时是怎么做到的呢？你是怎么找到这个现实生活的？嗯，所以当时我想，我从来没在办公室工作过。我毫无头绪。
So I literally opened the phone book and I looked for paper companies and there happened to be one in Glendale, the next town over from me, and I just called them up. I talked to the owner and I invited myself over there. To a Glendale paper company. Yeah. And the owner was so darling and I just went in there and was very respectful and was like, this is what I'm doing. I'm just trying to get a vibe and see what goes on here and see if I can kind of glean
所以我直接翻开电话簿，查找造纸公司，正好在我隔壁镇格伦代尔有一家，我就直接给他们打了电话。我和老板聊了聊，然后不请自大地去拜访了他们。去格伦代尔的一家造纸公司。是的。老板人太好了，我走进去时非常礼貌，说：“我正在做这个。我只是想感受一下这里的氛围，看看这里发生了什么，看看我能不能收集到
some details that maybe I wouldn't have normally known. But once I got in there, I was like, oh my God, I mean, having watched the English version of it, it couldn't have been more perfect. I mean, there was like inspirational posters that they had printed off their printer. So they were like super long and they went all the way down the hallway of like inspirational things. Just funny things posted, really personal things posted. There was a moose head in the, or maybe it was a deer.
一些我平时可能不会了解的细节。”但一旦我进去了，我就想，天哪，看过英国版的剧集后，这里简直不能再完美了。我的意思是，有他们自己用打印机打印出来的励志海报。所以它们超长，一直延伸到走廊，上面全都是励志内容。贴着各种有趣的标语，非常个人化的东西。仓库里还有一个驼鹿头，或者可能是只鹿。
A deer head in the warehouse, like just amazing details. So I took a million pictures and I took pictures of all the people. They were so kind to let me do that. Yeah. Literally all the characters were there in different iterations. Even Dwight was there, although he was this guy that wore like a wolf t-shirt. That is very Dwight. So did you take all those pictures and show them to Greg?
仓库里有个鹿头，细节实在是太棒了。所以我拍了无数张照片，还拍了所有人的照片。他们非常友善，让我拍照。是的。几乎所有角色都在那里，有各种不同的版本。甚至连德怀特也在，尽管他当时是个穿着狼头T恤的家伙。这真的很德怀特。所以你把所有这些照片都拿给格雷格看了吗？
Yeah. So I made a little slideshow and I put the little music, Welcome to the Working Week. And I brought it in for my first meeting with everybody and I was like, it's like playing and it's showing all these guys. Greg was like, what is this? Where is this? And you will take us there. Who all did you take there?
是的。所以我做了一个幻灯片，配上了一点音乐《欢迎来到工作周》。我把它带去参加我和大家的第一次会议，我就想，它正在播放，展示着所有这些家伙。格雷格说：“这是什么？这是哪里？你会带我们去那里的。”你都带谁去过那里？
So then we all went back and we took Greg. I think possibly Ken Quapas came with us, we took our production designer who was Donald Lee Harris at the time. I think our DP came and we just all trundled back over there. And this time we brought video cameras and we videotaped everything. What were these people thinking? They're like, I am selling paper in Glendale for years. And now all of a sudden, all of a sudden people want photos of my wolf shirt.
所以后来我们一起回去了，我们带上了格雷格。我想肯·夸帕斯可能也和我们一起去了，我们带上了我们的制作设计师，当时是唐纳德·李·哈里斯。我想我们的摄影指导也来了，我们大家一起慢吞吞地回到了那里。这一次我们带了摄像机，把一切都录了下来。这些人当时在想什么？他们会想，我在格伦代尔卖了好几年纸。现在突然之间，突然有人想要我的狼T恤的照片了。
What's happening? I took pictures of them out like smoking outside the warehouse and just all that stuff. All the little details. I still have that. I still use it as a slideshow. Sometimes when I teach costume design, you can't just go on Wikipedia and do your research. You have to go and see real people doing this. But I just think that's so fantastic, Carrie, that you're like, no, I'm going to go see
怎么回事？我拍下了他们在仓库外面抽烟的照片，以及所有这些琐碎的画面。所有的细节。我至今还保留着它。有时当我教服装设计时，我还会把它当成幻灯片来用。你不能只靠维基百科来做调研。你必须实地去观察真实的人们是如何工作的。但我只是觉得太棒了，卡莉，你当时想，不，我要去看看
what this looks like and then use that information to inform you about how to create Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. Yeah. So this trip to this Glendale paper company, it did not just inform the wardrobe of our show. It informed the entire look of our show. When you took those guys over to film, I know that they used that in the production design. They used it in so much of creating the world of Dunder Mifflin and that was all initiated
这到底是什么样子的，然后利用这些信息来指导你如何打造邓德米夫林。是的。是的。所以这次去格伦代尔造纸公司的行程，不仅仅是为我们节目的服装设计提供了参考。它奠定了我们节目整体的视觉风格。当你带那些家伙去拍摄时，我知道他们在制作设计中用到了这一点。他们在打造邓德米夫林的世界时大量借鉴了这一点，而这一切都是由你
by you. We have you to thank. Yes. We have you to thank for Dwight's mustard shirt. Like, how did you do that? How did you come up with these looks for the different characters? Oh, my gosh. Well, I mean, really, literally, the jumping off point was that office and just that vibe.
发起的。我们要感谢你。是的。我们要感谢你设计了德怀特的芥末黄衬衫。你是怎么做到的？你是如何为不同的角色想出这些造型的？哦，天哪。好吧，我的意思是，真的，绝对的起点就是那间办公室和那种氛围。
Like, that's what I'm saying. I have to feel immersed in that world. Otherwise, I can't do it justice. It will always feel a little bit fake. And the thing about what I saw there was that, and I think maybe in a lot of offices, is that the looks are slightly dated. Like, everybody's a little dated. So like, I kind of was having this, we did this like in the early 2000s, right?
就像我说的。我必须让自己沉浸在那个世界里，否则我无法做到公正。那样做总会感觉有点虚假。关于我在那里看到的景象，我想也许在很多办公室里也是如此，那就是造型都略显过时。就像每个人的打扮都稍微有点过时。所以我当时在想，我们拍摄这个大概是在2000年代初，对吧？
It was 2005, I think. So it was kind of like, I sort of, it was like early 90s was kind of where, or like almost even 80s. Like a little bit of that clunkiness, like just kind of, you know, not real polished was what I was after, which was actually the hardest line to hold with y'all. Keeping it not too polished, you know, like that's, I think that that gives it this vulnerability and sweetness is what makes the characters really, you know, attractive. Well, Carrie, I remember working in a real office and I didn't want to invest a whole
我想那是2005年。所以有点像，我某种程度上，感觉像是90年代初的那种风格，或者几乎是80年代的风格。带点那种笨拙感，就是那种，你知道的，不够精修的感觉正是我所追求的，而这实际上是你们所有人中最难把握的界限。保持不过于精致，你知道的，我觉得这赋予了角色一种脆弱感和甜美感，正是这一点让这些角色真正变得迷人。嗯，卡莉，我记得我在一个真正的办公室工作过，我不想在办公服装上投入太
lot of money in my office wear because I didn't super love my office job. So I thought of that with Pam. I remember thinking, I know she has to dress for work and I had to dress for work, but I want to put my money into my cute non-work clothes more than I want to spend a bunch of money on like expensive pants for work. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. You could choose, right?
多钱，因为我并不是超级热爱我的办公室工作。所以我在潘身上想到了这一点。我记得当时想，我知道她必须为工作着装，我也必须为工作着装，但我更愿意把钱花在我可爱的非工作服装上，而不是花一大笔钱去买昂贵的工作裤。对，没错。没错。你可以选择，对吧？
And so that's, that's reality. That's real life and you were trying to create a real life office environment. And that was 100% my idea with Jim because obviously, I mean, he's like this super handsome Hollywood guy. And I always imagined that he was probably borrowing his dad's stuff. Like maybe he grabbed a couple of ties from his dad's closet and that's why he always had those kind of woolly ties, you know, which I had great ones for the pilot and then it was really hard to keep finding those.
这就是现实。这就是真实生活，而你当时正试图创造一个现实生活中的办公室环境。这也是我为吉姆设计的100%的初衷，因为很明显，我的意思是，他就像是一个超级英俊的好莱坞帅哥。我总是想象他可能借了他爸爸的旧衣物。就像他可能从他爸爸的衣柜里拿了几条领带，这就是为什么他总是戴那种有点毛茸茸的领带，你知道的，我在试播集里为他准备了很棒的领带，但后来要一直找到那样的领带真的很难。
We actually ended up making them. But that kind of clunkiness, the sort of softness of him really helped bring him down, you know, make him just really sort of a real guy. But I always imagined that that's maybe where he got his closet from. Like he didn't necessarily shop for it. You have shared with Jen and I that you had a tie story for all the fellas. So that would be Jim's, right? That he was borrowing his dad's old ties.
我们最后实际上是自己制作的。但那种笨拙感，他那种柔和感，确实有助于抹平他的锋芒，你知道的，让他真正成为一个真实的人。但我总是想象，也许他的衣柜就是这么来的。就像他并不是非得去专门购物一样。你曾和珍娜还有我分享过，你为所有的男士都准备了一个领带故事。所以那是吉姆的故事，对吧？他借了他爸爸的旧领带。
What were some of the other ones? Michael's was just that he, I think they were ties that he thought were cool, but they were just kind of staticky. They just kind of look like static. And of course, like Dwight's, his whole muddy story, his, the mustard and the olives. See that that mustard shirt is kind of like a good luck thing that I do on my projects. And that has a backstory. That was from Scrubs, the wonderful director that pulled me onto that project, Adam Bernstein.
其他人的故事是什么样的？迈克尔的故事就是，我觉得那些领带是他自己觉得很酷，但它们看起来有点带静电。它们看起来就像静电干扰一样。当然，比如德怀特的，他整套“泥土风”的故事，他的芥末黄和橄榄绿。看，那件芥末黄衬衫就像是我在自己的项目中所做的一种好运仪式。这背后还有一个故事。那是来自《实习医生风云》，把我拉进那个项目的伟大导演亚当·伯恩斯坦。
He has a thing about mustard shirts and he was like, we just need a mustard shirt. It's just important. And now, and of course, then that show took off. And so now I try to put a mustard shirt, like it's just my thing. Mustard shirt. So wait, the mustard shirt is the good luck charm for you? Yes. That and, and I discovered like when I was shopping for this, I did a lot of shopping
他对芥末黄衬衫有种特别的情结，他说过，我们只需要一件芥末黄衬衫。这真的很重要。现在，当然，后来那部剧火了。所以现在我试着放进一件芥末黄衬衫，这就像是我的标志。芥末黄衬衫。等等，芥末黄衬衫是你的幸运符吗？是的。还有，还有我发现，当我为这个项目购物时，我在
at Mervyn's at JC Penney. And at the time in the men's section, you could buy a whole outfit, the suit, the shirt, the tie and the belt, all for like a hundred dollars. And they had all of his, all of Dwight's colors. They had there. And I just, it was just, I just blew my mind. I'm like, who's wearing these colors? You know, and I just thought it was so hilarious.
莫文百货（Mervyn's）和杰西潘尼（JC Penney）采购了很多。当时在男装区，你可以买到一整套衣服，西装、衬衫、领带和皮带，总共只要大约一百美元。而且他们有他所有的颜色，德怀特的所有颜色都在那儿。我当时简直惊呆了。我想，谁会穿这些颜色？你知道的，我当时觉得太滑稽了。
I'm like, that's what you would do. You would just buy the suit kit. Right. Especially Dwight, cause he's so efficient, right? He'd be like, well, there. Done. Yeah. Yeah.
我想，你就会这么干。你就会直接买一整套西装。特别是德怀特，因为他太讲究效率了，对吧？他会觉得，好啦。搞定。是的。是的。
Well, Carrie, I remember when I had to do an episode, it was the email surveillance episode where I had to wear casual clothes. Finally, I was going to get to wear jeans instead of a pencil skirt and hose. And when I came into my fitting, you had a whole bunch of jeans from old Navy, I think, and maybe the gap. And there was not one pair of designer jeans on the rack. And I noticed it because I had done other projects where I wore jeans and they would always put me in designer jeans.
嗯，卡莉，我记得当我要拍一集的时候，那是电子邮件监控那一集，我必须穿休闲装。终于，我不用再穿铅笔裙和连裤袜，而是可以穿牛仔裤了。当我来试装时，你带了一大堆牛仔裤，我想有老海军（Old Navy）的，可能还有盖璞（Gap）的。架子上没有一条设计师品牌的牛仔裤。我注意到了这一点，因为我以前拍过其他穿牛仔裤的项目，他们总是让我穿设计师品牌的牛仔裤。
And so I, I mentioned that, I said, I'm noticing you didn't buy any designer jeans. And you said, well, Jenna, Pam can't afford designer jeans. Pam has to only wear clothes that she can afford. And we picked out totally cute jeans, but I just was like, yes, I hate it when I watch TV and somebody is like a struggling pediatric nurse, $200 jeans, it drives me nuts. And so I just loved your integrity. Well, that, that episode in particular was Jim's barbecue, right? And we really got to see everybody as their true selves and, and really, and truly the
所以，我提到了这一点，我说，我发现你没有买任何设计师品牌的牛仔裤。你说，嗯，珍娜，潘买不起设计师品牌的牛仔裤。潘只能穿她买得起得衣服。我们挑了非常可爱的牛仔裤，但我当时就想，是的，当我在电视上看到某个角色是一个苦苦挣扎的儿科护士，却穿着200美元的牛仔裤时，我简直要抓狂了。所以我非常欣赏你的这种职业操守。嗯，那一集特别是吉姆的烧烤派对，对吧？我们真正看到了每个人最真实的一面，而且，真正让珍娜和我脱口而出的
one that stood out to Jen and I was Meredith. Like that was a very revealing outfit into Meredith's life. So, so yes, we'd love to hear more about that. I mean, those are the kind of episodes that, that totally throw me for a loop because you get in this rhythm of making these sort of, you know, we have our iconic looks, like we know, we know all the characters, but then will we still know them when they're in their everyday clothes? Like that always takes a lot of brain power.
一个人是梅雷迪思。那是一套非常能透露梅雷迪思生活的服装。所以，是的，我们很想听听更多关于这个的内容。我的意思是，这些类型的剧集完全让我陷入沉思，因为当你习惯了制作这种，你知道的，我们有标志性的造型，我们了解所有的角色，但当他们穿着日常服装时，我们还认得他们吗？这总是需要花费大量的脑力。
You know, that episode in particular, you guys were so invested in your characters by then. And I feel like that was, it's something kind of of an era. Like I don't always see that nowadays when I design stuff that the actors have thought through who they're being, but you guys were there and I always took my cue from anything. I mean, rain always would call me and be like, I have this idea, this hat, I've got this hat on my mind, you know, and, and it was the same with Meredith's outfit. Like she was like, I just feel like I should wear this biker jacket.
你知道，特别是那一集，那时候你们对自己的角色投入太深了。我觉得这有点时代的印记。现在当我设计服装时，我并不总是能看到演员们对他们所扮演的角色进行了如此深入的思考，但你们当时做到了，我总是从任何线索中寻找灵感。我的意思是，雷恩总是打电话给我说：“我有个想法，这顶帽子，我脑子里一直想着这顶帽子，”你知道的，梅雷迪思的服装也是如此。就像她说：“我只是觉得我应该穿这件机车夹克。”
Like, I think it just, it's like this whole side of me that nobody knows. I was like, okay, let's figure that out, let's work that in. I always say that as the costumes, I'm sort of the filter, I'm reading the script, I'm hearing from producers, I'm hearing from the actors, and then I'm putting my own spin on it too, but it's just all that information gels together somehow. And that's the magic. Well, I have a question for you. Dwight and Angela bumped some Birkenstocks in that episode.
就像，我觉得这展现了我身上别人都不知道的一面。我就说，好吧，我们来想想怎么弄，把它融入进去。我总是说，作为服装师，我某种程度上是一个过滤器，我阅读剧本，听取制作人的意见，听取演员的意见，然后我也在其中加入我自己的想法，但所有这些信息不知怎么地完美融合在了一起。这就是魔术般的时刻。嗯，我有个问题要问你。德怀特和安吉拉在那集里穿了勃肯鞋（Birkenstocks）。
And I remember, Gary, we had several like Birkenstocks for me to try on. Like I feel like you sort of also shaped that moment, like those two Birkenstocks. Do you remember that? You know what? That's such a perfect example of like that kismet that just kind of all the magic that all happens. Like we had those Birkenstocks because that was a product placement thing that we had. But the people that were offering us product placement because it was like an office show,
我记得，加里，当时你让我试穿了好几双勃肯鞋。我觉得你某种程度上也塑造了那个时刻，就像那两双勃肯鞋一样。你还记得吗？你知道吗？这绝对是一个完美的例子，展现了那种命中注定和所有魔法的发生。我们有那些勃肯鞋，因为那是我们的一项产品植入合作。但是那些向我们提供产品植入赞助的人，因为这是一部关于办公室的剧集，
it was all these really comfortable brands, like I think we had earth shoes and we had Birkenstocks, you know? But that free stuff was integral to costuming everybody because our budget was so tiny. I mean, just to give you an idea, I had, let's see, seven regulars on scrubs. I had 16 regulars on the office that I had to dress every show. I had $5,000 less a week to spend. Wow. So we were just always scraping, scraping, scraping.
全都是这些非常舒适的品牌，我想我们有地球鞋（Earth Shoes），还有勃肯鞋，你知道吗？但那些免费的赞助物品对于给每个人做造型至关重要，因为我们的预算实在是太少了。我的意思是，为了让你们有个概念，我有，让我看看，在《实习医生风云》里我有七个常规演员。在《办公室》里我有16个常规演员，我每集都得给他们穿衣服。我每周的可用预算却少了几千美元。哇。所以我们总是抠抠搜搜、精打细算。
So yeah, so we had a big box of Birkenstocks. But it fit. Like, you know, I thought it was a nice way to sort of like show that connection. And also like there's a foreshadowing of that moment in the episode. Like you show, you're like, I stepped in something with your Birkenstocks. So you see your Birkenstocks and then somehow he mentions his too and you see his. So I thought it was kind of great. It was like this moment where, oh, they both wear utilitarian shoes.
所以，是的，我们有一个装满勃肯鞋的大箱子。但它很合契。就像，你知道的，我觉得这是一种很好的方式来展现那种联系。而且，这一集里也有对那个时刻的伏笔。就像你展示的，你觉得，“我用你的勃肯鞋踩到了什么东西。”所以你看到了你的勃肯鞋，然后不知怎么他也提到了他的，你也就看到了他的。所以我觉得这挺棒的。这就像是一个时刻，哦，他们都穿着实用型的鞋子。
So anyways, it's just like one of those costume things like it just all like matched up into that beautiful moment. Well, I noticed in rewatching a few episodes that like my pants would be a little bit too long. Like mentioning seeing my feet in the Birkenstocks, like I, nothing was altered. Like very rarely did we alter anything. And I know that goes along with the budget you had, but I went on to do a show after the office and I have never been so altered in my life.
不管怎样，这就像是那种服装设计上的细节，所有这一切都完美地汇聚成了那个美好的时刻。嗯，我注意到在重温一些剧集时，我的裤子好像稍微有点太长了。就像提到看到我脚上的勃肯鞋一样，没有任何东西是修改过的。几乎很少有东西是修改过的。我知道这与你们当时的预算有关，但我后来在《办公室》之后去拍了一部剧，我这辈子从来没有做过这么多服装修改。
You know, the little seam on your shoulder. I realized all my shirts on the office, like the seam hit me like halfway down my arm. It was like all of a sudden every little thing was altered. And in rewatching like this episode in particular, I was like, oh, look how long my pants are. Right. But on purpose though, because I mean, that was the thing. It's, you know, it's so funny somewhere along the way Ricky Gervais came to our set and he's like, how's it going?
你知道，你肩膀上的那个小缝线。我意识到我在《办公室》里的所有衬衫，肩膀的缝线都垂到了我手臂的一半。就好像突然之间每一件小事都被修改过了。而在重温这一集，特别是这一集时，我就想，哦，看我的裤子有多长。对，但那是故意的，因为我的意思是，就是这样。这太有趣了，不知在哪个环节，瑞奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）来到了我们的片场，他说：“进展得怎么样？”
And I'm like, well, my biggest challenge is sort of holding the line and making everybody look really pedestrian because here they are these incredible Hollywood actors coming to work and they all look chic and they're cute little designer jeans. And I got to take them down a notch that like that's my job. And he was like, Oh my God, tell me about it. He was like, after the first season of the English office, like everybody came back. They were tan, they had their teeth were all fixed and white and I was like, Oh my God, thank you for feeling my pain.
我说：“嗯，我最大的挑战是守住底线，让每个人看起来都非常平庸，因为他们都是了不起的好莱坞演员，来这里工作时都穿着时髦的小衣服和可爱的小设计师牛仔裤。而我必须把他们拉低一个档次，这就是我的工作。”他当时就说：“哦，天哪，可不是嘛！”他说，在英国版《办公室》的第一季之后，每个人回来时都晒黑了，牙齿也都整修得洁白发亮，我当时就想：“哦，天哪，谢谢你感同身受。”
I know, we had, we had outfits. I remember fittings and Carrie, I'm like, Oh no, I feel like I should apologize where you would put something on me and I would go to like the cuter thing and I'd be like, what about that? And you'd be like, Angela, no, no, you don't get to wear that on the show. I know. It was really hard. It was really hard, but that I think that that is what makes the character so endearing
我知道，我们有过，我们有过的造型。我记得试装的时候，卡莉，我说：“哦，不，我觉得我应该道歉，”你给我穿上某件衣服，然后我会走向更好看的款式，我会说：“那件怎么样？”你会说：“安吉拉，不，不，你在剧里不能穿那个。”我知道。这真的很难。这真的很难，但我认为正是这一点让这些角色如此迷人
like that's because that's how real people are. Like they don't have everything tailored. It's off the rack. Well, sometimes you had to create wardrobe from scratch. Like in the fire episode, you had to create the uniforms that the fire department wore. And I remember you wanted it to be authentic to Scranton. Will you tell us that story? Okay, so there was no way to see what the fire department in Scranton looked like on
因为真实的人就是这样的。他们不会把每件衣服都量身定制。全都是直接买现成的。嗯，有时候你必须从头开始制作服装。就像在火灾那一集里，你必须制作消防部门穿的制服。我记得你想让它符合斯克兰顿的真实风格。你能给我们讲讲那个故事吗？好的，当时在互联网上根本不可能看到斯克兰顿消防部门的服装是什么样子的。
the internet. So I figured out the Chamber of Commerce in Scranton, Pennsylvania, and I called them up and amazingly, the amazing Mari answered the phone and I was like, I just explained everything. I'm like, I'm working on this TV show. I'm trying to recreate your fire department. Is there anybody who could go over there and take a picture of the patch for me? And she did it.
所以我找到了宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的商会，给他们打了电话。出乎意料的是，一位了不起的玛丽（Mari）接了电话，我就把一切都解释了一遍。我说：“我正在制作这部电视剧。我正试图重现你们的消防部门。有没有人能去那里帮我拍一张徽章的照片？”她真的照做了。
She actually did it. And she sent me this picture. That's amazing. So this woman you'd never met, gotten her car, drove to the fire department, took a photo. That's so great. And then she subsequently became the liaison between our show and Scranton, Pennsylvania. And I called on her for everything that we ever needed. Then Phil Shea, our prop guy, also got in on the action and we would just, we would just
她真的这么做了。她给我发了这张照片。太惊人了。所以这个你从未谋面的女人，上了车，开车去消防部门，拍了张照片。太棒了。然后她后来成为了我们剧组和宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿之间的联络人。我为我们需要的每一样东西都去找她。然后，我们的道具师菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）也参与进来了，我们就会
be like, Hey, is there a flower shop that would like to donate their, their aprons? Or how about the radio station? Could they send us some stickers? And then we started to get more savvy about it. Like Phil and I would coordinate and we'd be like, okay, we're going to need all these kind of things like delivery people, pizza guys, you know, and we just wanted it to be authentic. And she was willing to help us bless her soul.
比如问：“嘿，有没有哪家花店愿意捐赠他们的围兜？或者广播电台呢？他们能给我们寄一些贴纸吗？”然后我们在这方面变得越来越精明。比如我和菲尔会进行协调，我们会觉得，好吧，我们需要所有这些东西，比如送货员、披萨小哥，你知道的，我们只想让它看起来真实。而她愿意帮助我们，愿上帝保佑她。
Like she, she was, she made it, applause for Mari and Scranton, Pennsylvania. So she just, she just kept on with it. And over the years, we ended up doing a, a thing in the mall there. She hosted a thing, the radio station there and Phil went out there and businesses came and saw him. People were lined up out of the mall and they brought their stuff from their businesses. I remember this, Carrie, I remember it like walking into the kitchen after Phil had gone to the set kitchen and all of a sudden there were all of these Scranton menus from local
就像她，她做到了，为宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的玛丽鼓掌。所以她就一直坚持了下来。多年来，我们最终在那里的商场里办了一场活动。她主持了一场活动，当地的广播电台也参与了，菲尔去了那里，商家们都来看望他。人们在商场外排起了长队，他们带来了自己企业的物品。我记得这个，凯莉，我记得就像走进菲尔去过的片场厨房一样，突然之间，这里有了所有这些斯克兰顿当地的
restaurants. Yeah. All the magnets on the fridge, like every little detail you could imagine. It was amazing. I mean, he said that, he said that he was there for like five hours and he left to the go to the bathroom once. People followed him into the bathroom. I mean, it was, people brought the sweetest, funniest, most ridiculous things like cupcakes
餐厅菜单。是的。冰箱上贴满了磁贴，你能想象到的每一个小细节都有。太棒了。我的意思是，他说，他在那里呆了大约五个小时，只去了一次洗手间。人们甚至跟着他进了洗手间。我的意思是，人们带来了最贴心、最有趣、最荒谬的东西，比如印有
with your pictures on them. And I mean, it was amazing. I gave him the job to take pictures of every single person you see. If you can ask, ask their permission. Take pictures. I need people in uniform. I need kids. I need people on the street.
你们照片的纸杯蛋糕。我的意思是，这太棒了。我给他的任务是给见到的每一个人拍照。如果可以的话，征求他们的同意。拍照。我需要穿制服的人。我需要小孩子。我需要街上的人。
And he did that, which was amazing. I had another opportunity to do that too. One of the PAs on Scrubs was from there. And when he went back for Christmas vacation, I sent him with a camera and I was just like, if you could just take pictures of everybody you see, that would be awesome. He came back with a thousand pictures. Oh my gosh. And that just became my catalog.
不仅如此，我还有过另一个这样的机会。在《实习医生风云》里的一名制片助理就是那里的人。当他回去过圣诞假期时，我让他带着相机，我就对他说：“如果你能拍下你看到的每个人的照片，那就太棒了。”他回来时带了一千张照片。哦，天哪。而这成为了我的资料库。
I literally had a catalog of people and it was so amazing. So every time we had a new person on the show, it would be like, well, what kind of vibe do we want? Let's look at our people catalog. But that really also informed like how people wear things and how people combine outfits and just all of that. That is so fascinating to me and I just really respect it. I really respect the amount of research you did and how it just went on to continue over
我literally拥有一个人物资料库，这太棒了。所以每次我们在剧中有新演员时，就会想，好吧，我们想要什么样的人设氛围？让我们来看看我们的演员资料库。这确实也为人们如何穿衣、如何搭配服装以及所有这些方面提供了参考。这对我来说太迷人了，我真的很尊重这一点。我真的很尊重你所做的研究，以及它如何在之后的多年里继续为节目提供灵感。是的。
the years and form the show. Yeah. I just have to say it again. Your trip to the Glendale Paper Company informed the look of our show and then your idea to call the Chamber of Commerce set off a chain of events that like further specified our show. You are the boss lady. You are.
我必须再次说一遍。你前往格伦代尔造纸公司的行程为我们节目的视觉风格奠定了基础，然后你给商会打电话的想法引发了一系列事件，进一步细化了我们的节目。你是老大。你是。
Behind Dunder Mifflin. You are. You are the Dunder Mifflin like secret superpower. 100%. It just stems from like, I don't want to be audacious enough to think I know I'm the end all. I just think that real life is, what's that quote? If you can't see God in all, you can't see God at all.
邓德米夫林背后的功臣。你是。你就像是邓德米夫林的秘密超能力。100%是的。这源于我不想狂妄自大地认为自己无所不知。我只是觉得现实生活是，那句名言怎么说来着？如果你不能在万物中看到神，你就根本看不到神。
I think of that. I think if you're not looking at real life and noticing what makes it weird and wonderful, then you're missing out. You're really missing on those beautiful details that make something really special and really resonate. I feel like there's so many TV shows that are kind of, you know. That all look the same, right? Well, they're all, I totally get it.
我经常这样想。我认为如果你不审视现实生活，不去注意到是什么让它变得古怪而美好，那么你就错过了。你真的错过了那些让某事变得真正特别并真正引起共鸣的美丽细节。我觉得有那么多的电视剧，它们有点像……
You're moving fast and furious. It's so hard to get through those production schedules. There's so much work and you're doing so much. And, you know, and also here in Hollywood, there's so many resources for us. There's prop shops. There's costume shops. There's all that stuff. But if there's no little spark, little like, I don't know, the glitter, the little like
看起来都一样，对吧？嗯，它们全都是，我完全理解。你们的制作节奏紧张激烈。要赶完那些制作日程太难了。有那么多的工作，你们在做那么多的事情。而且，你知道，在好莱坞这里，我们有这么多的资源。有道具店。有服装店。所有这些东西。但如果没有一点火花，一点像，我不知道，闪光点，一点像
whatever that is, that's the, I don't know, just the spark. Like, that's what I always, I need to find that for myself, otherwise I kind of can't do the work. I think the office was unique in the sense too that it was trying to present a real slice of life. It was trying to find the beauty in the ordinary things. I mean, that's, that's what the point of the show was. And a lot of television shows, they are presenting a heightened version of reality.
无论那是什么，那就是，我不知道，仅仅是火花。就像，我总是需要为自己找到那个，否则我基本上无法完成工作。我认为《办公室》的独特之处也在于，它试图呈现真实的生活切片。它试图在平凡的事物中寻找美。我的意思是，这正是这部剧的意义所在。而且很多电视剧，它们呈现的是现实的升华版。
An idealized version of how a mom actually dresses, right? It takes super fashionable and put together at drop off as opposed to how I look at drop off. Right. So, you know, I think like our show was begging for the kind of work that you did on it. And it's what it needed. Yeah. All right.
一个关于妈妈实际上如何着装的理想化版本，对吧？在送孩子时显得超级时尚和得体，而不是像我送孩子时的样子。对吧。所以，你知道，我觉得我们的节目非常渴望你在上面所做的那种工作。而这正是它所需要的。是的。好吧。
Well, we, we are, we just love every single ounce of this information, like it's just so wonderful. But Carrie, do you have any memories that you would want to share about your time on the office, something maybe we haven't covered here? Oh my gosh. For me, it was like kind of this undoing of everything I knew, you know, in the sense that, um, and actually really this start, I have a great story that started really from the pilot, because as you do, you know, you do, when you're trying to get a show off the
嗯，我们，我们只是热爱这其中的每一丝信息，这实在是太美妙了。但是卡莉，你有没有什么想要分享的关于你在《办公室》工作的回忆，可能是一些我们这里还没有涵盖的事情？哦，天哪。对我来说，这就像是推翻了我所知道的一切，你知道的，从某种意义上说，呃，实际上从一开始，我有一个很棒的故事，真的是从试播集开始的，因为就像你所做的那样，你知道，当你试图让一部剧起步时，
ground, you do a lot of fittings. We have a lot of fitting pictures and you're kind of looking at what works. And then you're sort of, you know, each scene is like a painting really. And they get all the, all the players have to work together. And for me, it's kind of, I've just visually sort of putting the pictures together and making it all work color wise, um, if there's a pattern or anything. So on the pilot, we were all bustling around, you know, it was, we were trying to get that first shot and there was all this, you know, Hemen and Han about stuff and some costumes
你会做很多试装。我们有很多试装照片，你得看看什么效果好。然后你某种程度上，你知道，每一个场景就像是一幅画。所有的演员必须配合在一起。对我来说，这有点像在视觉上把这些照片组合在一起，在色彩上让它们协调，呃，如果有图案什么的。所以在试播集上，我们都在忙前忙后，你知道的，我们试图拍好第一个镜头，大家都在七嘴八舌地讨论，然后有些服装
got changed, um, kind of at the last minute, we were like, Oh no, that this would be better, this would be better. So when everybody appeared on set and we were doing the last looks, which, you know, the special thing about the office, and this was, this is a big part of my undoing was that there was no, you can't stand there and, and watch and, and fix. We weren't allowed on the set hair makeup wardrobe was not allowed. The set was closed. We would see you, put you in there and hope for the best.
在最后一分钟做了更改，我们当时想：“哦，不，这样会更好，那样会更好。”所以当每个人出现在片场，我们做最后检查时，你知道的，《办公室》的特别之处，这也是对我的一大颠覆，那就是没有那种——你不能站在那里观看和修正。我们不允许进入片场，发型、化妆、服装都不允许。片场是封闭的。我们会看着你，让你进去，然后祈祷一切顺利。
And that was huge because we're usually standing when you see things on TV, we're usually standing right there, like getting fixing it. So everybody had got, come to the set and Ken Cuapas, our director was there and I'm standing next to him. I'm just kind of observing and I go, Oh my God, there are three people, three guys are wearing white shirts. Like I never in my career with that, you always kind of, you know, mix, mix up the colors. I'm like, Oh my God, wait, hold on, I got to just, I got, I need to fix something.
这太重要了，因为通常当你在电视上看到某些东西时，我们通常就站在旁边，现场进行修正。所以每个人都来到了片场，我们的导演肯·夸帕斯也在那里，我站在他旁边。我只是在观察，然后我说：“哦，天哪，有三个人，三个家伙都穿着白衬衫。”我职业生涯中从来没有这样做过，你总是会，你知道的，把颜色混搭一下。我说：“哦，天哪，等等，我必须去修复一下。”
There's three people wearing white shirts. It's crazy. I've never do that. And Ken literally stopped me. He goes, because this bothers you, it's correct. And I was like, okay, but every, because it doesn't look right. It's perfect. It's perfect.
“有三个人穿着白衬衫。这太疯狂了。我绝对不会那样做。”而肯 literalmente 阻止了我。他说：“因为这让你感到困扰，所以它是对的。”我当时想，好吧，但是每个人，因为这看起来不对。这太完美了。这太完美了。
Right. And that was like, that was so huge for me that carried me through the whole thing because I would, from there on out, I would set the racks, you know, like say there was three days in the script. So I would set these huge racks, everybody's costumes. And I would sort of have like, as you do as a trained designer, you would kind of be like, well, this is sort of the blue show, the blue day, and this is kind of the green day. Just kind of the things like would work together and everybody would look harmonious.
对。这对我来说意义重大，它支撑着我完成了整部剧，因为从那时起，我会布置衣架，你知道的，假设剧本里有三天。所以我会布置这些巨大的衣架，每个人的服装。我会有一种，就像作为一个受过训练的设计师所做的那样，你会觉得，好吧，这有点像是蓝色主题日，而这有点像是绿色主题日。就是那种能搭配在一起、让每个人看起来都和谐的东西。
And I would set those three racks. And then I would literally just take like Angela's costumes and just go and mix them. Just flip them, just mix it. And even though it still to this day makes me feel a little sweaty. So you would like, you would do your design and it would be perfect and it would have the color harmony. And then you would purposely just mess it up. Yes.
我会把那三个衣架布置好。然后我会 literalmente 拿起像安吉拉的服装，直接去把它们打乱。直接翻转，把它们混搭。尽管直到今天，这依然让我感到有些冒汗。所以你当时会，你会做好设计，它本该是完美的，并且有色彩的和谐。然后你会有意地把它弄乱。是的。
And you'd be like, and now we have the office. And here we are. So good. Well, you know, I think what our listeners, one of the things we would want to share with you guys is on normal shows, between scenes, everyone comes flooding in to the actor, hair and makeup. You have like five set of hands on you. Maybe there's someone adjusting your mic.
然后你会说：“现在我们有了《办公室》。”我们就是这样。太棒了。嗯，你知道，我觉得我们的听众，有一点我们想要和你们大家分享的是，在正常的剧集里，场景之间，每个人都会蜂拥而至地走向演员，发型师和化妆师。你身上会有大约五双手。也许有人在调整你的麦克风。
Maybe wardrobe is fixing the bow on your shirt. And then hair and makeup is getting rid of a weird little flyaway hair and powdering your nose. And this all happens instantly. It's like, it's like the pit car at a race. Yes. Right? Yeah.
也许服装师在整理你衬衫上的蝴蝶结。然后发型师和化妆师在处理一根奇怪的飞翘头发并给你的鼻子扑粉。这一切都在瞬间发生。这就像是赛车比赛中的进站换胎。是的。对吧？是的。
You bring the car in and like all these people surround it. Yes. And then they hop out and then you're back on camera. And that never happened on the office. Right. Never. And so I remember one time we were like broken for lunch and I was leaving and I guess a few of my buttons, I had one of those shirts, oh my God, that had 32 buttons.
你把车开进来，然后所有这些人围着它。是的。然后他们跳开，然后你又回到了镜头前。而这在《办公室》里从来没有发生过。对。从来没有。所以我记得有一次我们正在拍午休戏，我正要离开，我想我的几个扣子，我有一件那样的衬衫，天哪，有32颗扣子。
And I guess a few at the neck had come open and you're like, how long were those open? I was like, I don't know. And you're like, okay. I guess that's what that's going to look like. I wish I knew your process all those years ago. I think I wouldn't have bugged you for a cuter blouse. But it's just so wonderful to hear how you shape the show. You are so smart.
我想领口有几个扣子散开了，你问：“那些扣子敞开多久了？”我说：“我不知道。”你说：“好吧。我想它看起来就是那个样子了。”我真希望多年前我就知道你的工作流程。我想我就不会一直烦你想要一件更可爱的衬衫了。但听到你是如何塑造这部剧的，真的是太美妙了。你太聪明了。
You're so good at your job. And the world of the office has a lot to thank you for. Yeah. You are one of the original visionaries of the show and it's pretty damn cool. Yeah. Well, I think so. I mean, I, you know, it's so funny because I was, I was so young back then that was just my process and thank you for, for honoring it and recognizing it.
你在工作中表现得太出色了。《办公室》的世界有很多需要感谢你的地方。是的。你是这部剧最初的远见者之一，这真是太酷了。是的。嗯，我也这么觉得。我的意思是，我，你知道，这太搞笑了，因为我，我当时太年轻了，那只是我的工作流程，谢谢你们尊重它并认可它。
All these, you know, all these years later, I just kind of did my, did my job. We all did. We were all just so into it. And now we're all old and jaded, but no, but we talked about that, Carrie. And I actually talked about it with Phil as well, because, you know, Phil Shea approached props the way you approached wardrobe, just detailed, detailed authenticity, authenticity. And we were saying, you know, back then we could all just like, you know, eat and breathe our work and our lives are more complicated now and they're filled out in other ways.
所有这些，你知道的，多年以后，我只是在做好，做好我的工作。我们都一样。我们当时都太投入了。现在我们都老了、疲惫了，不过不，我们谈过这个，卡莉。我和菲尔也讨论过这件事，因为，你知道的，菲尔·谢伊对待道具的方式就像你对待服装一样，充满了细节、细节、真实感、真实感。我们当时在说，你知道的，当年我们都可以只是，你知道的，全身心投入到工作中，把工作当饭吃，而我们现在的生活更加复杂了，在其他方面也更加充实了。
And, you know, it's hard to keep up a pace like that. So there was also like a perfect storm where we were all brought together at exactly the right time and exactly the right way in our lives, right? We were all sort of just starting out. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
而且，你知道的，很难保持那样的节奏。所以这也是一场完美的风暴，我们在生命中完全正确的时间和完全正确的方式汇聚在了一切，对吧？我们当时都正处于起步阶段。是的。是的。是的。是的。
Cool. Super cool. Well, thank you so much, Carrie. So amazing. Thank you, Carrie. Is there anything else we can share with people before you go? Where can we find you? Are you okay with people finding you?
太酷了。超级酷。嗯，非常感谢你，卡莉。太棒了。谢谢你，卡莉。在你离开之前，还有什么我们可以和大家分享的吗？我们在哪里可以找到你？你介意别人找到你吗？
Sure. Can we tell them anything you're working on? Sure. Yeah. You can find me. My Instagram is at Carrie Bennett costumes. And I tried to put some old pictures up there and keep people up to date on what I'm doing. I'm just about to start, um, head of the class, the reboot of head of the class.
当然。我们可以告诉大家你在做什么项目吗？当然。是的。你可以找到我。我的Instagram账号是 Carrie Bennett costumes。我试着在上面发布一些旧照片，让大家了解我的最新动态。我正准备开始，嗯，重启版《模范班级》（Head of the Class）。
So we'll see how that goes. What network is head of the class? Um, head of the class is going to be on HBO Max. Okay. So there you go. That's where you can find Carrie. You guys go follow and support her. We adore her.
所以我们看看进展如何。《模范班级》是在哪个电视网播出的？嗯，《模范班级》将在HBO Max上播出。好的。就是这样。这就是你可以找到卡莉的地方。大家去关注并支持她吧。我们非常喜爱她。
And Carrie, thank you so much. Thanks, Carrie. Thank you, ladies. It's so nice to be with you again. Just being in your presence. So this brings back all the good memories. It's such good days back then. I know.
卡莉，非常感谢你。谢谢你，卡莉。谢谢你们，女士们。能再次和你们在一起真是太好了。仅仅置身于你们当中。这勾起了所有美好的回忆。那时的日子真是太美好了。我知道。
Jenna and I say we want to have a big office ladies lunch and like call in all the office ladies. Not that we don't want the fellas there, but maybe maybe we just want the cows. I know. I don't want them there. I know. I was like trying to be nice. Um, all right.
珍娜和我经常说，我们想办一个盛大的办公室女士午餐会，把所有的办公室女士都叫来。倒不是说我们不想让男士们来，但也许，也许我们只想和姐妹们在一起。我知道。我才不想让他们来呢。我知道。我刚才还试图表现得友善一点。嗯，好吧。
I'm not going to try. I'm going to say my truth. Ladies only. I'm going to say my truth. The ladies were, the ladies were really special on that for sure. For sure. They kept the whole world running. We sure did.
我不再装了。我要说出我的真心话。只限女士。我要说出我的真心话。女士们，在这方面真的很特别。绝对是的。她们让整个世界正常运转。我们确实做到了。
All right. We are back. We are back. That was awesome. I'm still loving Carrie Bennett. I know. Me too. So hard crushing on her.
好的。我们回来了。我们回来了。太棒了。我还是很喜欢嘉莉·本尼特。我知道。我也是。超迷她的。
Hardcore love for Carrie Bennett. Should we get in to some good season four revisited stuff? Jenna, I can't wait. I know you have something and I'll have a little something and we haven't shared so that we would both hear it for the first time with you guys. You go first. All right. All right.
对嘉莉·本尼特爱得深沉。我们要不要聊聊第四季回顾的一些精彩内容？珍娜，我都等不及了。我知道你准备了点东西，我也有点东西，而且我们之前都没有分享，这样就能和大家一起第一次听到了。你先来。好吧。好吧。
I decided to do a title sequence breakdown because we haven't done it. We haven't talked about the credits. Oh, at the beginning of every show at the beginning of every show. And I want to say there's a reason why it's perfectly timed because the credits at the beginning of the show stayed the same all the way through season four. But as we move into season five, there are going to be changes. And now I'll be able to point them out because we will have done this breakdown. Okay.
我决定做一次片头序列剖析，因为我们之前没做过。我们没聊过片头字幕。哦，在每集节目的开头，每集节目的开头。我想说，这个时间点安排得非常完美，因为剧集开头的片头字幕在整个第四季中都保持不变。但当我们进入第五季时，将会发生一些变化。现在我将能够指出这些变化，因为我们已经做了这个剖析。好的。
I'm going to start with the theme song. Do it. The very famous office theme song, da, na, na, na, na, na, na. You know that one. That was created by composer James Ferguson. He has done music for tons of shows like NCIS Los Angeles. London's Murder Club, Melrose Place, Erie Indiana. He's done a lot.
我要从主题曲开始。开始吧。非常著名的办公室主题曲，哒，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦。你知道那一首。那是作曲家詹姆斯·弗格森创作的。他为无数节目创作过音乐，比如《海军罪案调查处：洛杉矶》。《伦敦谋杀俱乐部》、《飞越情海》、《印第安纳州伊利》。他做过很多。
He's also composed music for films like The Terminator, Charlie's Angels Full Throttle, and This Is Forty. He's the real deal. We got him. We got him for our theme song. But we almost didn't got him. What? There were three other options for songs.
他还为许多电影创作过音乐，比如《终结者》、《霹雳娇娃2：全速进攻》和《四十而惑》。他是真正的业内大咖。我们请到了他。我们为主题曲请到了他。但我们差点就没请到他。什么？这首歌当时还有其他三个备选。
Oh, I remember this. Is it coming back to you? Yeah. When Greg first thought, I'm going to use a song. Rather than use an original composition, he was going to use a song. And he whittled it down to three choices, and he created title sequences to all three songs, and he gave DVDs out to the whole cast, and we got to vote on these songs. We voted.
哦，我记起来了。你想起来了吗？是的。当格力格最初考虑时，我打算用一首歌。与其用原创作品，他打算用一首歌。他把它缩小到三个选择，并且为这三首歌都制作了片头序列，然后把DVD发给整个剧组，我们得对这些歌进行投票。我们投票了。
Let me tell you what the songs were. And we're going to play them so you can imagine the titles of Dunder Mifflin. Imagine Pam with her whiteout. Yeah. Pam with his adding machine, Dwight flipping his tie. Start with Better Things by The Kinks. Hmm. There's hope in all the days ahead, Hope be as bitter as the ones behind you, Be an
我来告诉你们这些歌是什么。我们要播放它们，这样你们就能想象出邓德米夫林的片头了。想象一下帕姆拿着修正液。对。帕姆拿着加法机，德怀特转动着领带。从奇нк乐队的《美好的事物》开始。嗯。接下来的日子里充满希望，希望也可能像你身后的日子一样痛苦，换作做一个乐观主义者吧，不知何故，幸福会找到你的。忘掉昨天发生的事吧。好的。好的。这是一个选择。好吧。我稍微有点感觉了。好的。
optimist instead, And somehow happiness will find you. Forget what happened yesterday. Okay. Okay. That's an option. All right. I'm filling it a little bit. Okay.
我是说，现在很难想象除了我们选择的之外还有什么别的，但好吧。我能理解。好吧。这是第二个选择。我知道有几个人建议这个。约翰，安吉拉。是的。盲目乐队的《飘浮》。
I mean, it's hard now to imagine anything but what we chose, but okay. I see it. All right. This is the second choice. I know a few people suggested this. John, Angela. Yes. Float on by Modest Mouth.
没错。好了，就是这样。是的，我是那首歌的超级粉丝。最后的选择是电光乐团的《蓝天先生》。我是说，我喜欢那首歌。我也很喜欢那一首。所以这就是我们的决定，各位。就是《蓝天先生》。
That's right. All right, there you go. Yes, I was a big fan of that one. Final choice was Mr. Blue Sky by E.L.O. I mean, I love that song. I love that one too. So here's what we decided, you guys. It was Mr. Blue Sky.
那一首。它赢了。我们在我家里举办了一场试播集观看派对，格雷格带过来一张DVD，我们的演职员表序列就是电光乐团的《蓝天先生》。没错。我到现在还留着那DVD。真的吗？是的。
That one. It won. We did a viewing party at my house of the pilot, Greg brought over a DVD and our credit sequence was E.L.O.'s Mr. Blue Sky. That's right. I still have the DVD. Do you really? Yes.
播放着切到《蓝天先生》的片头字幕。我想看那个。好吧，我们当时在等我们的节目播出。我们等了一段时间。在我们等待的时候，另一部节目播出了。它叫《洛杉矶国际机场》。由海瑟·洛克莱尔和布莱尔·安德伍德主演。它也是在NBC播出的。
Of the credits cut to Mr. Blue Sky. I want to see that. Well, we were waiting for our show to come out. We had to wait a while. While we were waiting, another show came out. It was called LAX. It starred Heather Locklear and Blair Underwood. It was also on NBC.
而且它是关于洛杉矶国际机场的？是的。好的。他们把《蓝天先生》用作了他们的主题曲。但是我们已经选了它。我知道。好吧。没关系。
And it was about the LAX airport? Yes. Okay. They used Mr. Blue Sky as their theme song. But we had picked it. I know. Well. Didn't matter.
发生了什么？我知道发生了什么。我开玩笑呢。我们不能用它了。所以格雷格不得不换掉它，也就是在那时，格雷格雇用了詹姆斯·弗格森（或者按他朋友的叫法叫他杰伊）来为我们写主题曲。哇。所以如果《蓝天先生》当时可用，那就会是我们的主题曲了。
What happened? I know what happened. I'm kidding. We couldn't use it. So Greg had to change it and that is when Greg hired James Ferguson or as his friends call him Jay to write our theme song. Wow. So if Blue Sky was available, that would have been our thing.
是的。我们的歌。是不是很疯狂？疯狂。所以我们直到我们第一集播出前一周，才录制了这首主题曲，那首著名的办公室主题曲。哦天哪。他们当时肯定急得直冒汗。
Yeah. Our song. Isn't that crazy? Crazy. So we did not record the theme song, the famous office theme song until one week before our first episode aired. Oh my gosh. They must have been sweating it.
他们当时手忙脚乱。所以格雷格在《布斯的剧组》里大概聊过这个。他有一个音乐人朋友鲍勃·蒂尔，他带着朋友们去录制了詹姆斯的曲子，录完之后，他们组建了一个乐队。他们自称为斯克兰顿人乐队，然后这个乐队就出现在了《布斯的剧组》里。没错。女士，我不想剧透，但我觉得有时我们的脑回路是一样的。
They were scrambling. So Greg kind of talked about this on Boos Crews. He had a musician friend, Bob Thiel, who went in with his friends and they recorded James's composition and after they recorded it, they formed a band. They called themselves the Scrantones and then that is the band that appears in Boos Crews. That's right. Lady, I don't want to give anything away, but I feel like sometimes we get same brain.
为什么？不，不，你会看到的。这毫无关系，但又息息相关。哦。好吧。我的趣闻就像是，这里有一条线索。你会看到的。我会看到的。
Why? No, no, you'll see. This is nothing related, but connected all the same. Oh. All right. My nugget is like, there's a thread. You'll see. I'll see.
好吧，我想跟你们多聊聊我们片头字幕的一些事。这具体是针对第四季的。就是在第四季期间，我们开始在片尾字幕时播放主题曲了。你们可能会注意到，在前三季里，片尾字幕都是静音的。哦，女士，我之前没意识到这一点。这真是个好发现。是的。所以从第四季开始，我们在片尾也开始播放主题曲了。
Well, I want to tell you some more things about our opening credits. And this is specific to season four. It was during season four that we started playing the theme song at the end credits. You might notice that in the first three seasons, it's silent credits. Oh, lady, I didn't realize that. That's such a good catch. Yeah. And so starting in season four, we started playing the theme song at the end as well.
正如你们所知，我们的主题曲是没有歌词的。它只是纯音乐，但克里德·布拉顿写了一些歌词。他确实写了。而且各位，它们太有趣了。我和他聊过这个，他说他每次出去巡演时，总是会对主题曲进行即兴哼唱。他们会播放它。然后他开始即兴抛出一些零星的歌词，纯粹是为了好玩。
As you all know, there are no lyrics to our theme song. It was just musical, but Creed Bratton wrote some lyrics. He did. And you guys, they are so fun. I talked to him about it and he said that when he would go out and go on tour, he would always riff on the theme song. They would play it. And he started throwing out little lyrics here and there just for fun.
对。他就像是在即兴发挥。是的。是的。但这让他开始思考，如果我坐下来真的写一些歌词会怎么样？它们会是什么样的？于是他最后写了一整首歌，而且真的太酷了。他在每场演出都会唱这首歌，我们现在要给你们播放其中的一小段。
Right. He was like improvising. Yeah. Yeah. But this got him thinking, what if I sat down and I did write lyrics? What would they be? And so he ended up writing a whole song and it is so cool. He plays it at every show and we're going to play a little bit of it for you now.
谢谢。斯坦利眯着半睁的眼睛说，和一个粉丝结婚了，比杰伊和芬迪一直都在想，但大卫·德夫林和布莱恩·罗伊，如果我没记错的话，就跟吉姆有过那么一次，哦等等。我们有弹斑卓琴的厄德·海尔姆斯，还有穿着凉拖的霍莉·弗拉克斯，还有托夫和那个，坏人的小喽啰。
Thank you. married to a fan said Stanley, with his eyes at half-mast. And BJ and Fendi thought all the time, but David Devlin and Blaine Roy, just that one time with Jim, if I recall, oh wait. We got Ed Helms with his banjo, and Holly Flax, the wearing sandals, and Tove and the, minor for a bad guy.
啊，各位，还没完呢。是的。他最后把办公室里的每个人都点名了一遍，简直太酷了。各位，你们一定要去现场看克里德的演出。他是一位了不起的音乐人。他的演出太有趣了。我很幸运去看了三场，我必须告诉大家，当他唱这首歌时，到场的几位剧组演员
Ah, you guys, it goes on. Yeah. He ends up naming everybody in the office, and it is so cool. You guys, you have to go see Creed Live. He is an amazing musician. His shows are so fun. I've been fortunate to go to three, and I have to tell you guys, when he played the song, several of the cast members
当他唱到我们的时候，我们全都走上了舞台。而且你知道的，他总是发短信给我，说，对不起，我拿你开涮因为你个子矮。但我们全都走上台去，手挽着手，然后全场观众也开始手挽着手，随着啦、啦、啦、啦、啦的部分摇摆。是的。
that were attending, we all walked out on stage when he sang about us. And you know, he always texts me, and he's like, I'm sorry, I throw you under the bus because you're short. But we all walked out on stage, and we locked arms, and then the whole crowd is locking arms and swaying to the la, la, la, la, la part. Yeah.
太甜了。这是一场多么美妙、有趣的演出。你猜怎么着？是的。他又去巡演了。哦，太棒了。这是你可以找到他的地方。在2021年9月，他将在爱达荷州、华盛顿州、
It's so sweet. It's such a wonderful, fun show. Guess what? Yeah. He is going back on tour. Oh, awesome. And here's where you can find him. In September of 2021, he's going to be in Idaho, Washington,
俄勒冈州和加利福尼亚州进行为期两周的巡演。然后他在2021年10月去澳大利亚。在2022年2月，他将前往爱尔兰和英国。你可以在 creedbratton.com 上找到他的整个巡演日程。没错。我们这群人里有好多，各位，每当他在加州演出时，只要我们能去，我们都会出现。
Oregon, and California on a two-week tour. Then he goes to Australia in October of 2021. And in February of 2022, he's going to be in Ireland and England. You can find his whole tour schedule at creedbratton.com. That's right. And a bunch of us, you guys, whenever he does shows in California, if we can, we show up.
我们会的。我们永远不知道日程会是怎样的或者怎样，但我设法赶上了几次，我太喜欢了。我喜欢他写了这些歌词。我也是。他可不是唯一一个写过歌词的人。什么？约翰·卡拉辛斯基主持了《周六夜现场》，
We do. We never know what the schedule is going to be or whatever, but I've managed to make a few, and I love it. I love that he wrote those lyrics. I do, too. He's not the only person who's written lyrics. What? John Krasinski hosted Saturday Night Live,
他也为我们的主题曲创作了一个演唱版本。没错。哦，你还去挖了料。我都把这事忘了。好吧，我们来听听那一首。最后，约翰·卡拉辛斯基演唱了原创办公室主题曲那失传已久的歌词，这也是他自己写的。斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，
and he did a song version of our theme song as well. That's right. Oh, you did some digging. I forgot about that. All right, let's listen to that one. Finally, John Krasinski sings the long-lost lyrics to the original office theme song, which he wrote himself. Scranton, Scranton, Scranton, Scranton, Scranton, Scranton,
斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿，斯克兰顿。这就是我们生活和工作的地方。那是个计算器。那是德怀特。他是坏人。英雄的名字叫吉姆，高亮显示。那是他的女朋友。那家伙在打电话。
Scranton, Scranton, Scranton, Scranton. That's where we all live and work. That's a calculator. There's Dwight. He's the bad guy. And the hero's name is Jim Highlighting. That's his girlfriend. That guy's on the phone.
泰伊活着。然后又是我的镜头。尼克·哈雷尔做了拿奖杯的那个动作，办公室。哦，天哪。约翰唱出了那个低音，办公室。我知道，我知道。我觉得太有趣了。好吧，主题曲就聊到这儿。
Ty's live. Then there's me again. Nick Harrell does the trophy thing, the office. Oh, my gosh. John hit in that low note, the office. I know, I know. I thought that was so fun. All right, that covers the theme song.
我觉得我聊透了。主题曲说完了。接下来呢？我们得聊聊屏幕上真正的片头字幕。哦，对，对。视觉画面。我来为你们剖析一下。出现在开场字幕中的五位演员
I feel like I've covered it. You've got the theme song. Now what? We have to talk about the actual credits on the screen. Oh, right, right. The visuals. I'm going to break it down for you. The five actors featured in the opening credits
带有画面的有史蒂夫、雷恩、约翰、我和比杰伊。还有布莱恩的手。还有布莱恩的手。我们之所以会出镜，是因为我们是剧集开拍时签了常规合同的演员。在整个第一季和第二季的一部分时间里，其余的配角都被列为客串明星
with images are Steve, Rain, John, me, and BJ. And Brian's hand. And Brian's hand. And the reason that we were featured was because we were the actors who had regular contracts when the series started. For all of season one and part of season two, the rest of the supporting cast are listed as guest stars
在片尾字幕中。但后来，当你们成为剧集的常规演员时，你们的名字开始在片头主标题之后、剧集开始时出现，编剧和导演的名字也同时出现。没错。这可是件大事。他们管这叫正片开头，各位。
in the end credits. But later, when you guys became series regulars, your name started to appear after the main titles as the show begins, where the writers and directors are also credited. That's right. It was a big deal. They call it top of show, guys.
正片开头。如果作为一个演员，你的名字能出现在正片开头，那就相当于开派对啦。你们在开场字幕里看到的斯克兰顿的镜头，都是由约翰·卡拉辛斯基拍摄的。没错。约翰在得到吉姆·哈珀特这个角色时住在纽约。
Top of show. If your name gets in the top of show as an actor, that's party time. The shots of Scranton that you see in the opening credits, those were shot by John Krasinski. Yep. John was living in New York when he got the role of Jim Helpert.
在被选中出演该剧之后、但我们开始拍摄之前，他和他的朋友决定开车去斯克兰顿，并为那里的一家当地纸业公司拍摄一部迷你纪录片。他们采访了人们。他们采访了斯克兰顿一家纸业公司的经理，是一位女性。在这次旅行期间，
And after he was cast on the show, but before we started shooting it, he and his friend decided to drive to Scranton and do a mini documentary on a local paper company there. They interviewed people. They interviewed a manager of a paper company in Scranton who was a woman. And while they were on this trip,
他们还拍摄了斯克兰顿的画面。这些画面最终进入了片头字幕。没错。就像是一个车拍镜头。我觉得他们当时拿的是手持摄像机。确实是的。他的朋友有一辆吉普车。约翰就那样把身子探出窗外。
they also shot images of Scranton. And these are the ones that made it into the credits. That's right. It's like a driving shot. And I feel like they had like a handheld camera. They did. And his friend had a jeep. And John was just like hanging out the window.
所以那个拍摄钢笔、纸张和供应大楼的镜头，华盛顿街莫尔伯里大街上的斯克兰顿中心，以及斯克兰顿欢迎标牌，全都是由约翰拍摄的。关于那个斯克兰顿欢迎您的标牌，有一个有趣的小花絮。它现在已经不在路边了。关于为什么会这样，我听过两个说法。一个是他们不得不把它拆下来，因为有太多人停下来和它拍照，这很不安全。
So the shot of the pen, paper, and supply building, the Scranton Center on Mulberry in Washington, and the Scranton welcome sign were all shot by John. Here's a little fun fact about that Scranton welcomes you sign. It is no longer on the side of the road. Now, I've heard two stories about why this is. One is that they had to take it down because too many people were stopping to take pictures
哦，好吧。嗯，这说得通。我是说，它就在高速公路旁边。对。另一个说法是它在暴风雨中被吹倒了。这有点像是官方说法。对。我不知道。
with it, and it was unsafe. Oh, OK. Well, that makes sense. I mean, it's on the side of like a highway. Right. The other is that it blew over in a windstorm. That's sort of like the city official story. Right. I don't know.
不管怎样，你还是能看到它。它被重新安置到了蒸汽城购物中心的二楼。所以你可以和它合影。它就在凯饰珠宝店旁边。是的。我很高兴他们把它保存下来了，而且它还在商场里。太完美了。是的。
Either way, you can still see it. It was relocated to the second floor of the Steamtown Mall. So you can take a picture with it. It's next to the K Jewelers. Yes. I love that they saved it, and it's in the mall. It's perfect. Yeah.
此外，当约翰在那里采访那位纸业公司女经理时，她的办公桌上有一个毛绒仓鼠小玩具。所以我不知道你们有没有注意到，在迈克尔的办公桌上，在他身后的小边柜上，也有这些毛绒仓鼠小玩具。当格雷格在约翰的素材里看到它们时，他说，我也想在我们经理的桌上放仓鼠。
Also, while John was there when he was interviewing the woman who was the manager of the paper company, she had a little stuffed hamster on her desk. And so I don't know if you noticed, but on Michael's desk on the little credenza behind him, there are these little stuffed hamsters. And when Greg saw them in John's footage, he said, I want to put hamsters on our manager's desk too.
穿着小衣服的仓鼠。我记得其中一只好像在乐队里？他是要打鼓吗？我不知道。我总觉得其中一只穿着背心。是的。我猜我是把它放进军乐队里了。但我不知道它实际上是不是在干这个，
Hamsters and little outfits. I think one of them is like in a band? Is he going to play the drums? I don't know. I always feel like one of them had a vest on. Yeah. I guess I'm putting him in a marching band. But I don't know if that's what he's really doing,
不过它确实穿着背心。我一直以为它是个精致的家伙。一只精致的小仓鼠。片头序列中绝大多数演员的镜头都来自《办公室》的第一季。德怀特拿着碎纸机的镜头来自《多元化日》。吉姆打电话的镜头也来自《多元化日》。我接电话的镜头
but he does have on a vest. I just always thought he was a fancy guy. A little fancy hamster. Most of the shots of the actors in the title sequence are from the first season of The Office. Dwight's shot with the shredder is from Diversity Day. Jim on the phone is also from Diversity Day. The shot of me answering the phone
是《同盟》中被删掉的片段。瑞安打电话的镜头来自《试播集》。德怀特翻领带和瑞安拿着一袋衣服的镜头都来自《篮球赛》。吉姆和帕姆的镜头来自《辣妹》。迈克尔调整他的邓迪奖杯是B面素材。在前四季中，我们的开场序列里有一个镜头发生了变化，那就是史蒂夫的镜头。
is a deleted scene from The Alliance. Ryan on the phone is from The Pilot. Dwight flipping his tie and Ryan with his bag of clothes are both from Basketball. And the shot of Jim and Pam is from Hot Girl. Michael adjusting his Dundee was B-roll footage. There is one shot that changed in our opening sequence in the first four seasons, and that is the shot of Steve.
史蒂夫在第一季中的定场镜头来自《多元化日》。但在第二季中，他们把它换成了《性骚扰》中的镜头，因为他们想配合他更新后的形象，我们在第二季中改变了他的造型。这里有个有趣的花絮。人们总是在谈论那张被高亮标记的纸，
The establishing shot of Steve in season one was from Diversity Day. But they changed it in season two to a shot from sexual harassment because they wanted to match his updated image, because we changed his look in the second season. Here's a fun fact. People always talk about that piece of paper that's
因为它是用荧光笔圈出来的，而不是用荧光笔涂亮的。那张纸来自洛杉矶城市规划局。好吧，我觉得这真的很酷，因为我之前没意识到开场字幕竟然融合了这么多不同的剧集。
getting highlighted because it gets circled with a highlighter rather than highlighted with a highlighter. That piece of paper is from the Los Angeles Department of City Planning. Well, I think that's really cool because I didn't realize the opening credits was such a mix of so many different episodes.
你知道的，配角在里面只出现了一毫秒。我们就出现在会议室里。你知道我的意思吗？是的。瑞安接电话的时候你就那个镜头里。对。我们就在他身后。我猜那是来自《试播集》。
You know, the supporting cast is in it just for a millisecond. We're like in the conference room. You know what I mean? Yes. You're in that shot when Ryan answers his phone. Right. We're behind him. And I guess that was from The Pilot.
那是来自《试播集》。我之前没意识到。那也就意味着凯特·弗兰内里不在那个镜头里，因为她没有出演我们的试播集。哦，对。我是说，画面非常快。但这太酷了。这就是我看完片头字幕后的感受。
That was from The Pilot. I did not realize that. And that would mean that Kate Flannery is not in that shot because she was not in our pilot. Oh, yeah. I mean, it's very quick. But that's so cool. That's kind of what I got going through the credits.
我觉得我剖析得很透彻。随着我们进入第五季，我很兴奋，因为现在我能告诉你们都有哪些变化了。变化正在发生。敬请期待。当我们回看第四季时，我真的在DVD里仔细挖掘了一番。我发现了一个NBC制作的宣传片，
I think I broke it down. I'm excited as we move into season five because now I'll be able to tell you the changes. There's change happening. Day tuned. As we were looking back on season four, I really did some digging on the DVDs. And I found a commercial that NBC put together
旨在向观众推介《办公室》。所以这就是NBC的第四季宣传片。它当时在那个时期播放。每隔一段时间，就会出现一部深受评论家喜爱、观众为之欢呼的喜剧。我感到非常幸运。欢迎来到办公室，每周四晚恭候光临。我会在乎我没被邀请去迈克尔的晚宴吗？
to highlight the office to its viewers. So here is NBC's commercial of season four. It ran during this time. Every once in a while, a comedy comes along that critics love and audiences cheer for. I feel very blessed. Welcome to the office, where you're invited every Thursday night. Do I care that I wasn't invited to Michael's dinner party?
所以找一个你爱的人，安顿下来。我有个单人朋友。一艘普通的划艇能载着她而不至于翻船吗？你没有回答我的问题，这让我很烦。办公室，每周四在NBC播出。等等，他们在第四季刚开始时播了这个？里面有剧透啊。不，不，不。
So grab someone you love and settle in. I have a friend who's single. Would an average rowboat support her without capsizing? It bothers me that you're not answering the question. The Office, Thursdays on NBC. Wait, they ran that at the beginning of season four? There's spoilers in that. No, no, no.
他们在末尾播的。你知道我的意思吗？那是夏天的重播，我不知道，珍娜。他们在第四季结束时播的。他们确实播了，这是我们知道的。我们可以非常确定地告诉你们，他们播了那个宣传片。我喜欢那种旁白，就像是，
They ran it at the end. You know what I mean? It was summer reruns and I don't know, Jenna. They ran it at the end of season four. They ran it is what we know. What we can tell you with great authority is they ran that commercial. And I love that it is this guy that's like,
找一个你爱的人。找个舒服的姿势。看你最喜欢的办公室伙伴。我喜欢那个家伙的嗓音。我是说，更准确的说法应该是，开始做晚饭，把它作为背景音乐打开，在你打扫房子时播放它，办公室。我们随时陪伴你。
find someone you love. Get comfortable. Watch your favorite office folks. Like that guy's voice. I mean, what would be more accurate would be like, start making dinner, turn it on in the background, have it play while you clean the house, the office. We're here for you.
我觉得这才是现在人们看《办公室》的方式。对，或者他们本该让演德怀特的雷恩出来说，别当个笨蛋了，快看，拜拜。没错。我们真该给《办公室》制作宣传片。好吧，我只是觉得在DVD里意外发现这个挺好玩的。各位去看看第四季第一张光盘，
I feel like that's how people watch the office today. Right, or they should have just gotten rain as Dwight to be like, don't be an idiot, watch it, bye. Exactly. We should make the commercials for the office. Well, I just thought that was a fun thing to stumble across on the DVDs. And you guys go to season four, disc one,
你们就会看到那个带有播报员大叔声音的宣传片了。那么，安吉拉，你还有什么别的料吗，因为你在笑，而且在整理纸张。好吧，这是我在整理纸张。这是我深度挖掘出的一点小料。好吧，我知道我们之前聊过第一届办公室大会。珍娜，你当时去不了。
and you'll see the commercial with Mr. Announcery Guy. Now, what else do you have, Angela, because you're smiling and you're shuffling papers. Okay, this is me shuffling papers. Here's a little something I did a deep dive on. All right, I know we talked a little bit about the very first office convention. Jenna, you weren't able to go.
我们今年聊过这个。是的。嗯，我决定对办公室大会进行一番深度挖掘，因为它发生在第四季期间。各位，我挖出了一个绝妙的猛料。我太高兴你做这个了。好吧，这就是我发现的。根据斯克兰顿大学的皇家新闻报道，
We talked about that this year. Yeah. Well, I decided to deep dive the office convention because it took place during season four. And you guys, I uncovered something delicious. I am so glad you did this. Okay, so here's what I found. According to the University of Scranton's royal news,
斯克兰顿的第一届办公室大会于2007年10月26日至28日举行。这里有一些快讯。哦，他们有快讯，珍娜。我们有快速事实，而皇家新闻有快讯。好吧。3000名观众与《今日秀》的阿尔·罗克以及包括我在内的剧组成员们见面，
the very first the office convention in Scranton was October 26th through 28th, 2007. Here's some quick facts. Oh, they have quick facts, Jenna. We have fast facts and the royal news has quick facts. All right. 3,000 people greeted Al Roker of the Today Show with members of the cast, including me,
进行了一场来自校园的现场直播。《今日秀》周末版也从校园进行了直播。400名斯克兰顿大学的学生为大会做了志愿者。在为期三天的活动中，有10,000人参加了办公室大会。3400人参加了在大学朗中心举行的剧组问答会。
for a live broadcast from campus. The Today Show Weekend Edition also broadcast from campus. 400 University of Scranton students volunteered for the convention. 10,000 attended the office convention over a three-day period. 3,400 attended a Q&A with the cast at the university's Long Center.
157名记者参加了大会，其中包括来自《洛杉矶时报》、《纽约时报》、《今日美国》、《MTV》、《VH1》和《美联社》的记者。哇。所有这些数字都意味着这是一场盛大的活动。我是说，如果你去斯克兰顿亲眼看看这个小镇，然后意识到有157家媒体到场，
157 journalists attended the convention, including reporters from the Los Angeles Times, the New York Times, USA Today, MTV, VH1, and the Associated Press. Wow. All those numbers mean this was a big event. I mean, if you go to Scranton and see the town itself and then realize 157 press outlets were there,
你会发现每条街上都有事情在发生。那里有街头节、邓德米夫林无限公司的办公室奥运会，有出售斯克兰顿相关商品的食品和当地摊贩，还有两个提供各种现场娱乐表演的露天舞台。此外，还有与剧组成员的问答座谈会、博主早餐会以及编剧室讨论会。但女士，我们剧组去参加的许多人，
there was something happening on every street. There was a street festival, Dunder Mifflin Infinity's Office Olympics, food and local vendors selling Scranton-related merchandise, two open-air stages offering a wide assortment of live entertainment. There was also a Q&A panel with cast members a blogger's breakfast and a writer's block discussion. But lady, a lot of us from the cast that attended,
我们不得不乘飞机在不同时间抵达。你猜是谁拉开了整个办公室大会周末的序幕？谁？克里德·布拉顿和凯特·弗兰内里与斯克兰顿人乐队一起表演。是的。我看过这方面的录像。是的。他们被邀请表演宾夕法尼亚波尔卡舞。
we had to fly in at different times. Guess who kicked off the whole the office convention weekend? Who? Creed Bratton and Kate Flannery performing with the Scranton. Yes. I saw footage of this. Yes. They were asked to perform the Pennsylvania polka.
我不得不打电话给凯特。我得就这事给她打电话。我在YouTube上看过一个画质模糊的视频。我说，凯特，请告诉我这是怎么回事。她说，安吉拉，这太棒了。我们知道到了斯克兰顿后根本没时间彩排。所以鲍勃·蒂尔召集了斯克兰顿人乐队。
And I had to call Kate. I had to call her about it. I saw a grainy YouTube video of it. I was like, Kate, please tell me about this. She said, Angela, this was amazing. We knew we wouldn't have time to rehearse once we got to Scranton. So Bob Thiel gathered the Scranton's band.
鲍勃弹吉他。他的朋友迪伦弹钢琴。布莱恩打鼓。哈尔弹贝斯。戴夫弹贝斯。来自威瑟乐队的斯科特·施赖纳也弹了贝斯。什么？是的。
Bob played guitar. His friend Dylan played piano. Brian played drums. Hal was on bass. Dave was on bass. And Scott Schreiner from the band Weezer also played bass. What? Yes.
但准备好听这个了吗？什么？“怪人阿尔”扬科维奇。加入了他们在录音室里的彩排。什么？是的。他和鲍勃是朋友。而且他那天本来就要去录音室。
But ready for this? What? Weird Al Yankovic. Joined them in the studio to rehearse. What? Yes. He is friends with Bob. And he was going to be at the studio that day anyways.
所以鲍勃就说，嘿，你能过来在我们的彩排里拉手风琴吗？等等，那“怪人阿尔”后来跟他们一起去斯克兰顿了吗？没有，没有，没有。他只是在他们于洛杉矶的录音室彩排的那天恰好在那里。好吧。但他确实狠狠地帮了他们一把。
So Bob said, hey, can you come over, play the accordion at our rehearsal? Wait, did Weird Al go to Scranton with them then? No, no, no. He was just there the day they rehearsed in the studio in Los Angeles. OK. But he totally helped them out.
你准备好听这个了吗？鲍勃录下了彩排过程。凯特问他我们能不能在播客里播放这段录音。他说可以。所以它就在这儿。克里德·布拉顿、凯特·弗兰内里、“斯克兰顿人”乐队以及“怪人阿尔”在演奏《宾夕法尼亚波尔卡》。[《宾夕法尼亚波尔卡》音乐]
And are you ready for this? Bob recorded the rehearsal. And Kate asked him if we could play it on the podcast. And he said yes. So here it is. Creed Bratton, Kate Flannery, The Scrantons, and Weird Al playing the Pennsylvania Pocah. ["The Pennsylvania Pocah"]
我很感动。我很情绪化。是不是很有趣？我来告诉你们为什么。各位，演员们参加大会是没有片酬的。你们当时是没有报酬的。他们支付了你们的机票。是的。
I'm very moved. I am emotional. Isn't that so fun? Let me tell you why. You guys, the cast was not paid to attend the convention. You guys were not paid for this. They paid your airfare. Yes.
还有酒店。他们承担了我们的食宿。但我们所做的一切都是出于对这部剧的热爱和对粉丝的热爱。这些人走进录音室，利用自己的时间进行彩排。然后他们把这场演出带给粉丝和斯克兰顿。这就是我
And your hotel. They got our room and board. But everything else we did was for the love of the show and the love of the fans. And these guys went into a studio and they rehearsed on their time. And then they brought this show to the fans and to Scranton. And this is one of the things that I
特别喜欢克里德和凯特的地方，他们就像是那种老派的表演者。演出必须继续。我们要呈现出最棒的演出。他们身处其中是因为他们热爱它，热爱表演，热爱给人们带来快乐。当我听到这段彩排录音时，我内心充满了各种感触。
love about Creed and Kate especially is that they are like those old school performers. The show must go on. We're going to make the best show possible. They are in it because they love it and they love performing and making people happy. And when I heard this rehearsal tape, it just gave me all the feels.
是的，真的太棒了。如果你能在YouTube上找到它，我找到了其中一个版本。他们不仅倾情演唱，还在四处载歌载舞，全心全意地为斯克兰顿的《办公室》粉丝们表演《宾夕法尼亚波尔卡》。我只是觉得这太酷了，
Yeah, it really was so amazing. And if you can find it on YouTube, I found one version of it. Not only are they singing their hearts out, they're dancing around, they are fully committed to doing the Pennsylvania Pocah for the Office fans in Scranton. And I just thought that was so cool
他们为整个大会开了一个好头。我爱他们。他们太棒了。太棒了。谢谢鲍勃·蒂尔、“斯克兰顿人”乐队以及“怪人阿尔”。好吧，这就是我关于斯克兰顿第一届办公室大会所找到的一些趣事。
that they started off the whole convention. I love them. They're awesome. Awesome. And thank you to Bob Thiel and the Scrantons and Weird Al. Yeah. Well, that's some trivia that I found about the very first the Office convention in Scranton.
我觉得真的很有趣。我太喜欢这个了。我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为接下来我们还有关于特定剧集的新发现。好吧。我是说，你们以为我们聊完了，各位。我们还发现了更多料。我只想说两个词。
I thought it was really fun. I am loving this. I think we should take a break because now we have stuff that we discovered about specific episodes. All right. I mean, you thought we covered it, you guys. We found more stuff. I'm just going to say two words.
晚宴派对。哦，对。我们马上回来。我们将聊聊第四季的一些剧集和一些新内容。但我想从这个开始。Office Tally，你们知道我们的网站，我们挚爱的网站。我们爱珍妮·谭。
Dinner party. Ooh, yeah. We'll be right back. We are going to talk about some of the episodes from season four and some new stuff. But I thought I'd start with this. Office Tally, you know our website, our beloved website. We love Jenny Tan.
没错。每一季，他们都会对剧集进行排名，粉丝们会投票选出他们心目中的单季最佳剧集。哦，你要告诉我第四季粉丝最爱的是哪集吗？是的。所以在第四季的14集当中，根据Office Tally粉丝的投票，排名第一的剧集
That's right. Every season, they would do rankings of the episodes fans would vote on their favorite episodes from a season. Oh, are you going to tell me the fan favorite for season four? Yes. So of the 14 episodes from season four, according to Office Tally fans, the number one ranked episode
是《人体模型》。真的吗？是的。紧随其后的是第二名的《告别托比》。第三名是《金钱》，而《晚宴派对》在14集中排名第九。还记得吗，我们之前聊过这个。我们说过刚播出时这并不是粉丝的最爱。
was chair model. Really? Yes. That was followed by goodbye Toby in second place. And money in third place, dinner party, was ranked ninth out of 14 episodes. Remember, we talked about that. We said this was not a fan favorite when it first aired.
没有。它是那种我觉得在多次重温之后热度才逐渐飙升的剧集。是的。但在第一次观看时，它排名第九。第九。第十四。我们开始吧，安吉拉？
No. It is the type of episode that I think caught momentum after many rewatches. Yes. But on the first watch, number nine. Number nine. Number 14. Should we get started, Angela?
我想你有什么关于《趣味长跑》的事要告诉我。我有的。所以惠特尼·克罗伊和其他几个人问我，安吉拉，当我和德怀特为了小不点大吵大闹时，我们在跑步也在争吵，迈克尔从我们中间慢跑过去，在我们吵架时从我们中间慢跑过去时，低声说了句什么。好的。
You've got something to tell me about Fun Run, I think. I do. So Whitney Croy and a few other people asked me, Angela, when you and Dwight are having that big argument about sprinkles, we're running and we're fighting, Michael jogs between us and says something kind of under his breath as he jogs between us while we're fighting. OK.
迈克尔说了什么？大家都说，请告诉我们他说的是什么。我当时听不清。我回去看了。我开着字幕重新看了一遍，因为当迈克尔在安吉拉和德怀特的关系基本上走向终结时从他们中间跑过，我也不知道他说了什么。迈克尔压低声音说，认真对待蝙蝠咬伤。
What does Michael say? People were like, please tell us what he says. I could not make it out. I went back. I rewatched with subtitles because I didn't know what he said either as he runs between Angela and Dwight as their relationship is basically ending. Michael under his breath says, take bat bite seriously.
别被咬了。他边跑边传播狂犬病防范意识。没错。所以惠特尼，谢谢你来信。其他几个人也问了。我这儿有一个来自梅丽莎·威廉姆斯的趣闻，她想跟我们聊聊关于《发布会》的事。好的。
Don't get bit. He's just spreading rabies awareness as he runs. Right. So Whitney, thank you for writing in. A few other people did as well. I've got a little nugget from Melissa Williams who wants to tell us something about launch party. OK.
《发布会》是梅丽莎带着石膏回来、想要吉姆签名那一集。我们当时对她到底是怎么穿着这个石膏上厕所的感到非常困惑。对。我们在质疑骨盆骨折是不是需要打石膏。对，或者说你的石膏看起来是不是像一条巨型内裤。是的。
Launch party is when Meredith comes back with her cast and she wants Jim to sign it. And we were very confused about how she goes to the bathroom in this cast. Right. We were questioning if you need a cast for a broken pelvis. Right, or if your cast looks like a giant pair of underwear. Yeah.
嗯，梅丽莎·威廉姆斯想让我们知道，确实有一种覆盖整个骨盆的石膏，叫做髋人字石膏，它是用于股骨骨折的。它会覆盖你的整个骨盆、整条腿以及另一条腿的一部分。但裆部有一个开口，上面横跨着一根栏杆。这就是你在打着全身骨盆石膏时如何嘘嘘的方式。
Well, Melissa Williams would like us to know that there is a cast that covers the whole pelvis and it's called a spica cast and it is for a broken femur. It covers your whole pelvis and all of one leg and some of the other leg. But there's like an opening in the crotch and there's a bar going across it. And that's how you pee in your full pelvic cast.
哦天哪，听起来太可怕了。是的。因为如果你上厕所时不够整洁怎么办？我是说。如果溅出来了。有时候事情不会按计划进行。是的。
Oh my god, that sounds horrible. Yeah. Because what if you're not always tidy when you go to the bathroom? I mean. If it sprays. Sometimes things don't go according to plan. Yeah.
不过，那清理起来会很难吧。我猜如果你是个男的，可能会简单点。你可以把你的那个。我们是从女性的角度来看的。他们可能会瞄得更准一些。我也这么觉得。嗯，梅丽莎，谢谢你分享这个。女士们，千万别骨折股骨，不然你们
But well, that'd be hard to clean up. I guess if you're a man, it's easier. You could put your thing. We're looking at it from a woman's perspective. They might could aim it better. I would think so. Well, Melissa, thank you for sharing that. Ladies, don't break your femur because then you
可能就得打髋人字石膏了。裆部带个洞。还有一根栏杆，可能还带点尿液飞溅。哦，好吧，希望那会是唯一的飞溅物。那还会有什么别的飞溅物？如果那是覆盖你整个骨盆的石膏的话。哦天哪。你还得拉粑粑呢。
might have to have a spica cast. With a hole in the crotch. And a bar and maybe some pee spray. Oh, well, let's hope that's the only spray. What would the other spray be? If it's a cast for your whole pelvis. Oh my god. You have to go poop, too.
我甚至都没想到拉粑粑这事。我甚至都没想过还得在石膏里拉粑粑。是的。我没想到。那是我想到的第一件事。哦，当你说事情不会按计划进行时，你指的是拉粑粑。是的。
I didn't even think of the pooping. I didn't even think about having to poop in the cast. Yes. I didn't think about it. That's the first thing I thought of. Oh, when you said things don't go as planned, you meant pooping. Yes.
哦，哇，我之前没想到。我是说，现在我觉得太糟糕了。我知道你刚才脸都红了。就像你刚意识到什么一样。哦天哪，你会把粑粑弄到那个石膏上的。我知道。这是不可避免的。我知道。
Oh, wow, I hadn't. I mean, now I feel so horrible. I know you just turned bright red. It's like you just realized something. Oh my god, you're going to get poop on that cast. I know. It's unavoidable. I know.
或者弄到栏杆上。情况越来越糟了。哦天哪，我们真不该拿这个开玩笑。好吧，我们希望你们都好好的，永远不用穿那种东西。梅丽莎，谢谢你的分享。你有什么料，女士？好吧，我们聊到哪了？
Or on the bar. It's getting worse. Oh my god, we shouldn't be laughing about it. All right, we hope you guys are well and don't ever have to wear one of those. And Melissa, thank you for sharing. What do you got, lady? Well, where do we go?
好吧，好吧。在删减片段里，各位，我发现了一些我觉得对《当地广告》来说非常有趣的事。还记得《当地广告》吗，每个人都在推销他们关于邓德米夫林广告应该是什么样的想法？是的。托比提出了他的想法，然后我们发现了一些关于托比的事，这些并没有出现在剧本宝典里。
OK, all right. In the deleted scenes, you guys, I found something I thought was very interesting for local ad. Remember local ad, everyone is pitching their ideas about what the Dunder Mifflin commercial should be? Yes. Toby pitches his idea, and we find out something about Toby that was not in the show Bible.
是什么？他之前的工作。好吧，还有其他人吗，没有烂点子了吧？大家？我们继续集思广益。好的，托比。嗯，你们知道现在每个人看广告都会快进吗？那么，做一个慢动作的广告怎么样？
What is it? His previous job. All right, so anybody else, no bad ideas? Everybody? Let's keep them coming. OK, Toby. Well, you know how everyone fast-forward to ads these days? Well, what about an ad in slow motion?
你知道的，如果他们快进着看，它看起来就会很正常，而且能吸引眼球。另外，广告标语可以是：邓德米夫林。我们适应您业务的步伐。没有不好的点子，但就这个点子而言，真的是烂透了。我在来到这里之前在广告行业干了三年。而这大概就是为什么大多数广告都那么烂。
You know, if they fast-forward through it, it'll just seem normal and it'll catch your eye. Plus, the slogan could be Dunder Mifflin. We adapt to the pace of your business. There are no bad ideas, but for an idea, that was really, really bad. I spent three years in advertising before I came here. And that is probably why most ads suck.
哦，哦天哪。托比在广告业干了三年。而且那真的是个好主意。我知道，大家都挺喜欢它的。哦天哪，太棒了。托比不一直都是人事部的家伙，他曾是个广告人。托比本可以是个广告狂人。这里有个联动。
Oh, oh my god. Toby worked in advertising for three years. And that's a really good idea. I know, everybody really liked it. Oh my gosh, that's so good. Toby wasn't always the HR guy, he was the ad man. Toby could have been a madman. There's a crossover.
这里有个联动。另外，在《当地广告》中，你们当中的几个人指出，女士们，不仅吉姆在现实生活中把德怀特的订书机放进了果冻里，而且在《当地广告》的删减片段里，在第二人生里，吉他吉姆把德怀特的巴祖卡火箭筒放进了果冻里。哦，对。嗯，我回去找了找。7分49秒。
There's a crossover. Also, in local ad, a few of you pointed out, ladies, not only does Jim put Dwight Stapler in Jell-O in real life, but that in the deleted scenes for local ad, in second life, guitar Jim puts Dwight's Bazooka in Jell-O. Oh, yes. Well, I went back and looked. Seven minutes, 49 seconds.
你们说得对。如果你去看看DVD，或者也许我会把它放到播客里，你就会看到了。有趣的是，我也挖掘到了一点关于“第二人生”的趣闻。什么？所以我们告诉过你们，我们为德怀特和吉姆建立了一个真实的“第二人生”。
You guys are correct. If you go to the DVDs, or maybe I'll put it in the pod, you'll see it. Interestingly enough, I have a little second life trivia as well, that I uncovered. What? So we told you that we set up a real second life for Dwight and Jim.
嗯，德怀特的“第二人生”角色，名叫德怀特·K·谢尔福德。他在2008年5月6日星期二向“第二人生”的所有玩家发布了一则公告。它的标题是《安吉拉的宝宝》。哦！上面是这么写的。注意，员工们。邓德米夫林的“第二人生”分部
Well, Dwight's second life, Dwight K. Shelford, was his name. He made an announcement in second life to all of the second life players on Tuesday, May 6, 2008. And it was titled, Angela's Baby. Oh! And here's what it said. Attention, employees. Dunder Mifflin's second life branch
想要欢迎邓德米夫林无限公司大家庭的最新成员，伊莎贝尔·鲁比女士，于5月3日星期六出生，她的父母为此感到骄傲。啊。请提前注意，伊莎贝尔女士体重6磅14盎司，在工作时睡觉，并且没有高等数学技能。她还会牙牙学语，并且能够喷射式呕吐。谢谢，德怀特。
would like to welcome the newest addition to the Dunder Mifflin Infinity family, Ms. Isabel Ruby, born on Saturday, May 3 to her proud parents. Aw. Be forewarned, Ms. Isabel weighs 6 pounds, 14 ounces, sleeps on the job, and has no higher math skills. She also babbles and is capable of projectile vomit. Thanks, Dwight.
哦天哪，我不知道他们做了这个。嗯，那就像我们的剧组一样，他们为你感到那么骄傲，安琪，为你那么高兴，以至于他们向我们仍在运行的“第二人生”账号发送了这份小公告。这让我太感动了。所以我们也有很多人在询问关于杰森·雷特曼在《当地广告》的一个音频片段中所说的一句评论。
Oh my gosh, I didn't know they did that. Well, that was just like our crew, who was so proud of you, Ange, and so happy for you that they sent out this little announcement to our second life account that was still going. That is so moving to me. So we also had a lot of people asking about a comment that Jason Reitman made in one of his audio clips for local ad.
他说过“冷即是喜剧”这句话，大家都在问我们能不能多解释一下这是什么意思。我是说，我们的片场冷得不可思议。是的。嗯，我想这的意思是，有一个传统，大卫·莱特曼的片场就非常冷。哦，冻死人了。
He said the phrase, cold is comedy, and people were asking if we could explain more of what that meant. I mean, our set was incredibly cold. Yes. Well, I think what it means is there is a tradition, and David Letterman's set was so cold. Oh, freezing.
冻僵了。冻僵。这种观点认为，当你身体太热时，比如如果你觉得太暖和了，你在喜剧方面就不会保持机敏。所以这是一个非常著名的现象，很多喜剧演员和喜剧表演者都喜欢冷一点的环境，因为我不知道。这能让你保持清醒。让你的大脑保持清醒。
So freezing. Freezing. This idea that when you're too hot physically, like if you're too warm, you're not on your toes comedically. So it's a very famous thing that a lot of comedians and comedic performers like it cold, because I don't know. It just keeps you. Keeps your brain awake.
是的，没错。因为你知道当你变热时会发生什么吗？热天里，你会变得懒洋洋的。你开始打瞌睡。你会觉得，整个人都蔫了。嗯，你绝对不希望观众处于温热状态。你不会希望你的观众暖洋洋的。没错。
Yes, that's right. Because you know what happens when you get hot? A hot day, you're sluggish. You start to fall asleep. You're like, bleh. Well, you definitely don't want a warm audience. You don't want your audience warm. That's right.
是的。所以我们把片场保持得非常非常冷。这出于两个原因。第一，冷即是喜剧。第二，史蒂夫穿西装时真的会觉得很热，尤其是特别热。为了帮他保持“冷即是喜剧”的状态，我们把片场保持得很冷。
Yeah. So we kept our set very, very cold. And that was for two reasons. One, cold is comedy. And number two, Steve got really hot in his suits, like especially hot. And so in order to help him stay cold as comedy, we kept our sets really cold.
是的，我也听说在剧院和摄影棚里，用来照亮舞台、照亮片场的灯光，那些设备会变得非常非常热。所以你某种程度上也是在对抗那种热量，保持所有让演出得以继续进行的设备处于凉爽状态，可以这么说。我个人的感觉是，当我暖和的时候我也能非常搞笑。我挺能接受这一点的。
Yes, and I've also heard in theaters and studios that the lights they use to light the stage, to light the set, that equipment gets very, very hot. And so you're sort of combating that heat as well, keeping all of the instruments cool that help the show go on, so to speak. My personal feeling is that I can be very funny when I'm warm. I'm OK with it.
我挺习惯又暖和又搞笑的。你知道吗？我们从来没机会尝试过。我从来没在一个暖和的片场待过。我从来没有走进片场然后说，哦，我不知道，我们穿个背心吧。没有。我走进片场都是穿着派克大衣的。
I'm OK being warm and funny. You know what? We've never been able to try. I've never been on a warm set. I've never walked onto a set and been like, ooh, I don't know, we're a tank top. No. I walk on a set in a parka.
我倒挺乐意表现得温暖有趣的。你知道吗？我们以前从没机会尝试过。我从没进过氛围轻松的片场。我从没走进片场觉得，哦，我不知道，我们可以穿背心。不。我每次走进片场都穿着羽绒服。
Always. Always. I have on four layers right now. Is warm is drama? Is it that we haven't done enough dramas? Dramatic actors, are you warm all the time? Because maybe I need to switch gears here. Let's ask, who can we ask?
总是。总是。我现在穿了四层。是暖和还是戏剧？难道是我们拍的剧情片还不够吗？演剧情片的演员们，你们一直都这么暖和吗？因为也许我得在这里改变一下策略了。我们问问，我们可以问谁？
Kate Winslet? We don't know her, but let's write her an email. If we don't know her, how are we going to get her email? David Denman is doing that show with her. Oh my god, you're going to hit up David Denman for Kate's email. Kate, I'm calling you by your first name. And then our first question to Kate Winslet, who we've never spoken to, is, are sets warm for dramas?
凯特·温丝莱特？我们不认识她，但我们给她写封电子邮件吧。如果我们不认识她，我们要怎么拿到她的邮箱？大卫·丹曼正在和她一起拍那个节目。哦，天哪，你要去找大卫·丹曼要凯特的邮箱。凯特，我直接叫你的名字了。然后我们向一个从未说过话的凯特·温丝莱特提出的第一个问题是，拍剧情片的片场都很暖和吗？
When you do dramas, here's what I think we could do. You're right. That's ridiculous. We can't show our ass to Kate Winslet. The first time we talked to her. Let's ask David to just ask her. On set. Just be like, bring it up casually, David.
当你拍剧情片时，我觉得我们可以这么做。你是对的。太荒谬了。我们不能在第一次跟凯特·温丝莱特说话时就出丑。让大卫去问她吧。在片场。就好像，随口提一下，大卫。
Be like, Kate, I'm curious. Are all of your sets warm because you're doing dramas? And she'll be like, that's a weird question, but it'll be on David. But we'll still get the answer. But also, David might just say, hey, you boholes, you can ask me. I am also on the dramatic set, standing next to Kate.
就说，凯特，我很好奇。你们所有的片场都很暖和，是因为你们在拍剧情片吗？她会觉得，这是一个奇怪的问题，但这得怪大卫。但我们还是能得到答案。不过话说回来，大卫也可能会说，嘿，你们这两个笨蛋，你们可以问我啊。我也在剧情片的片场，就站在凯特旁边。
I know, but I need someone who's been on almost exclusively dramatic sets to really give me a real answer. OK, you need an overview. And David really straddles it. He does both. Well, maybe actually now that I think about it, he's the perfect person to ask because he could tell me if there's a temperature shift between comedy and drama.
我知道，但我需要一个几乎只待过剧情片片场的人来真正给我一个确切的答案。好吧，你需要一个全局了解。而大卫其实两边都沾。他两类都拍。好吧，也许现在想来，他其实是最佳人选，因为他可以告诉我在喜剧和剧情片的片场之间是否存在温度差。
There it is. And now we don't have to bug Kate Winslet. I was looking forward to getting to know her. I'm sure you guys would have really bonded via email about temperatures on sets. You never know. It's true, you never know. Why am I being such a snark?
这不就对了。现在我们不用去烦凯特·温丝莱特了。我还挺期待去了解她的。我确信你们俩会通过电子邮件就片场温度这个话题结下深厚的友谊。你永远说不准。确实，你永远说不准。我为什么这么爱挖苦人？
Yeah, like Kate Winslet's going to be your fringe. Just you wait. You're going to feel real dumb one day when I show up somewhere with Kate Winslet. When you start podcasting with Kate Winslet, I'm going to be so bummed. And the name of our podcast is Drama Is Warm. Drama Ladies.
对啊，好像凯特·温丝莱特会成为你的死党一样。等着瞧吧。总有一天，当我带着凯特·温丝莱特出现在某个地方时，你会觉得自己像个大傻瓜。当你开始和凯特·温丝莱特一起做播客时，我会超级难过的。我们播客的名字就叫《剧情很暖和》。剧情辣妈。
Yeah, there you go. Should we move on? What do we got next? I want to know if you got to the bottom of what Michael was eating in Survivor Man. Yes, I did. OK, good. You told me you were digging.
对，就是这样。我们继续吧？接下来有什么？我想知道你有没有弄清楚迈克尔在《荒野求生专家》里到底吃了什么。对，我弄清楚了。好吧，太好了。你之前告诉我你在深挖。
OK, this is actually a crossover catch between Money and Survivor Man. OK. We were dying to know what were the pellets in the bag. Yes. Tom Corey Lewis wrote in. He thinks, Michael is eating Dwight's bag of wild oats that he would have received from his parents
好吧，这其实是《金钱》和《荒野求生专家》之间的一个跨界彩蛋。好的。我们非常想知道袋子里的颗粒到底是什么。对。汤姆·科里·莱维斯写信来了。他认为，迈克尔吃的是德怀特父母留给他的、用来向女人求爱的一袋野燕麦。
for courting a woman. I checked the show Bible. According to the show Bible, in the Money episode, Dwight says there is a shrewd family tradition for parents to leave a bag of wild oats on the doorstep after their male child has had sex. Oh my god. So Tom thinks maybe these are the oats.
我查了剧集圣经。根据剧集圣经，在《金钱》那一集里，德怀特说他们家有一个精明的传统，就是当家里的男孩子发生性关系后，父母会在门廊上留下一袋野燕麦。哦，天哪。所以汤姆认为这些可能就是那些燕麦。
These are the sex oats. And he had them. And he gave them to Michael. They're the sex oats. Oh my gosh. Naughty oats. Naughty oats. Naughty oats being eaten in the wilderness.
这些就是“性爱燕麦”。而且他留着它们。他还把它们给了迈克尔。这就是性爱燕麦。哦，天哪。淘气燕麦。淘气燕麦。在荒野里吃着淘气燕麦。
Oh, now that is a product right there. Naughty oats. Naughty oats. Sex oats. N-A-U-G-H-T-Y, Naughty Oaks. What are we making, cereal? Yeah. I kind of like the name Naughty Oaks.
哦，这可真是一款产品啊。淘气燕麦。淘气燕麦。性爱燕麦。N-A-U-G-H-T-Y，淘气橡树。我们在做什么，麦片吗？对。我其实挺喜欢“淘气橡树”这个名字的。
Are you saying oaks or oats? Naughty oats. Naughty oats. Naughty oats. I want to eat that cereal. But do you want it to be called sex oats or naughty oats? That's tough. You can't have a cereal called sex oats.
你刚才说的是橡树（oaks）还是燕麦（oats）？淘气燕麦。淘气燕麦。淘气燕麦。我想吃这种麦片。但你是希望它叫性爱燕麦还是淘气燕麦？这很难办。你不能做一种叫性爱燕麦的麦片吧。
It's got to be naughty oats. All right. I'll eat it. So your four-year-old could be like, Mom, I can't have naughty oats. I don't say that, that's terrible. I know. It's an adult cereal.
它必须叫淘气燕麦。好吧。我会吃的。这样你四岁的小孩就可以说，妈妈，我不能吃淘气燕麦。我不会这么说，这太可怕了。我知道。这是成年人的麦片。
Why? For adults only. Why? Because it's naughty. It makes you have sex. No, you eat it after sex. What are the shapes? Are they naughty shapes?
为什么？仅限成年人。为什么？因为这很淘气。它会让你想做爱。不，你是在做爱之后吃。有什么形状？是淘气的形状吗？
A little penises and boobies. Oh, Lord. What has happened to us in this podcast today? I don't know. I don't know. All right. Dinner party, Angela? Oh, yeah.
小阴茎和小咪咪。哦，天哪。我们今天这个播客到底怎么了？我不知道。我不知道。好吧。晚宴派对，安吉拉？哦，对。
Listen, I didn't think there was any way that we would uncover anything that we hadn't already covered in dinner party. I thought that was a pretty thorough episode. I thought so. I was very proud of that episode. Well, let me put my glasses on, because James Zepedia came through.
听着，我本来觉得我们不可能再挖出什么我们在《晚宴派对》里还没涵盖的东西了。我觉得那一集已经非常透彻了。我也这么觉得。我为那一集感到非常自豪。好吧，让我戴上眼镜，因为詹姆斯·泽佩迪亚发来好东西了。
James shared with me the candy bag talking head alts. You guys remember what candy bags are, right? We shared this with you. Dinner party was 100% scripted. The script was amazing. Nothing was changing. But when we would go to do a talking head, the standard on our set was writers
詹姆斯跟我分享了糖果袋独白备选项。大家还记得什么是糖果袋吧？我们之前跟你们分享过。《晚宴派对》是100%按剧本拍摄的。剧本棒极了。什么都没改。但每当我们要做独白时，我们片场的标准就是编剧会塞给我们一堆备选项。
would hand us a bunch of alts. Yeah. And we called these candy bags. You had your talking head that was the quote, must shoot. From the script. From the script. And then we had the candy bags.
对。我们把这些叫做糖果袋。你有一段必须拍摄的剧本台词独白。来自剧本。来自剧本。然后我们有糖果袋。
I want to share two candy bag alt talking heads, one for Jim and one for Dwight. I cannot wait. This is a talking head for Jim that did not, obviously, make it in dinner party. But it really made me laugh. Here it is. If I had known that Michael would make everyone stay late,
我想分享两个糖果袋的独白备选项，一个是吉姆的，一个是德怀特的。我等不及了。这是吉姆的一段独白，显然没有最终剪进《晚宴派对》里。但它真的让我笑喷了。给你。如果我知道迈克尔会留所有人很晚，
just to trap me and Pam into a couple's only dinner at his condo with Jan, Andy, and Angela, I would have never asked Pam out in the first place. And I really like Pam. Isn't that funny? That's so good. OK, so that was a candy bag alt for dinner party. And then I was texting with Rain,
只是为了把我和帕姆困在他的公寓里，和简、安迪以及安吉拉一起吃情侣专属晚餐，我当初就根本不会约帕姆出去了。而且我真的很喜欢帕姆。是不是很好笑？太棒了。好吧，那是《晚宴派对》的一个糖果袋备选项。然后我跟雷恩发短信，
because we actually did a Q&A with University of Scranton. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, we had a great time over Zoom. Anyway, we were texting, and I was like, Rain, I just found an alt talking head for Dwight for dinner party. And Rain read it as Dwight and sent it in as an audio clip. And you guys remember, this talking head is in reference to Dwight and Angela's relationship.
因为我们实际上和斯克兰顿大学做了一场问答。对，没错。对，我们在Zoom上玩得很开心。总之，我们在发短信，我就说，雷恩，我刚刚找到了一个德怀特在《晚宴派对》里的独白备选项。然后雷恩以德怀特的口吻读了它，并作为音频片段发了过来。你们还记得，这段独白是指德怀特和安吉拉的关系。
A farmer and his plow horse have a strong bond, because they have a shared mission. But what mission do a man and a woman have? None, really. So they're left to just stare at each other blankly, waiting for the other one to flinch or die or say something cute. Horses never say anything cute, but if they did,
农夫和他的耕马有着深厚的纽带，因为他们有着共同的使命。但男人和女人有什么使命呢？其实没有。所以他们只能大眼瞪小眼地互相盯着，等着另一个人畏缩、死去或者说点可爱的话。马从来不说可爱的话，但如果它们会说，那可就是件大事了。
it would be a really big deal. There were several alts for Dwight, where he is just comparing Angela and Dwight to some kind of farming analogy. But that one made me laugh. Thank you, Rain. You know, and Rain is always so supportive of the Office Ladies podcast.
德怀特有几个备选项，都是他把安吉拉和德怀特比作某种农耕类比。但那个真的把我逗笑了。谢谢你，雷恩。你知道的，雷恩总是那么支持“办公室辣妈”播客。
Really shows up for us. I love you, Rain. I know. He's a good friend. He's like a tall, sweet, crusty friend. Yes. And you guys, his podcast Metaphysical Milkshake is now available on all platforms
真的很支持我们。我爱你，雷恩。我知道。他是个好朋友。他就像一个高大、温柔、有点脾气的朋友。对。还有大家，他的播客《形而上奶昔》（Metaphysical Milkshake）现在可以在你听播客的所有平台上收听了。
where you listen to podcasts. It's Rain and his friend, Reza Aslan. They talk about life's big questions. He's a good person to do that. I call him when I have big questions. And I mean it. I'm not joking. I know.
这是雷恩和他的朋友雷扎·阿斯兰（Reza Aslan）共同主持的。他们讨论生活中的重大问题。他是个做这种事的合适人选。我有重大问题时就会打电话给他。我是认真的。我没开玩笑。我知道。
So guys, go give it a listen. I wish we could have Rain read all of Dwight's candy bag talking heads. I bet all the candy bag talking heads are so good. Because the thing about the candy bag talking heads was that they would push it. The writers could swing big, right? And sometimes they would make it in.
所以大家去听听看吧。我真希望我们能让雷恩读完德怀特所有的糖果袋独白。我敢打赌所有的糖果袋独白都太棒了。因为糖果袋独白的特点是它们尺度很大。编剧们可以大胆发挥，对吧？有时候它们会被剪进正片。
But I think more than anything, those candy bag talking heads were just for their amusement. They just wanted to hear us say the stuff that was the biggest swing. I'm going to move us on to Chair Model. You know, in Chair Model, Creed is collecting chairs? Yeah. We got a comment from Eve Elizabeth
但我认为最重要的是，那些糖果袋独白只是为了取悦他们自己。他们只是想听到我们说出那些最大胆的话。我要带大家进入《椅子模特》。你知道，在《椅子模特》里，克里德在收集椅子？对。我们收到了伊芙·伊丽莎白的评论，
who said that Creed's talking head about needing three chairs could have been a reference to Thoreau who said this, quote, Henry David Thoreau? Yeah. OK. He said, I had three chairs in my house. One for solitude. Two for company.
她说克里德关于需要三把椅子的独白可能是对梭罗的致敬，梭罗曾说过这样的话，引述如下，亨利·大卫·梭罗？是啊。好吧。他说，我在房子里有三把椅子。一把为了独处。两把为了陪伴。
Three for society. I'm only laughing because of the way you said society. Society. Society. Yeah. Wow. Well, I mean, I sort of believe that Creed would like Henry David Thoreau.
三把为了社交。我笑只是因为你刚才说“社交”那个词的方式。社交。社交。是啊。好吧，我是说，我倒有点相信克里德会喜欢亨利·大卫·梭罗。
Why not? All right. Goodbye, Toby. Remember, we did our show Bible goodbye to Toby. Yeah. We promised we would do one for Karen. Let's do it. Here it is.
为什么不呢？好吧，再见，托比。记住，我们对托比做过剧集圣经式的告别。对。我们答应过要为凯伦做一个。我们开始吧。就是这样。
Karen Philippelli speaks French and can also speak some Italian. She's very into Call of Duty, and her favorite chips are hers, Salt and Vinegar. After getting kicked out of the party planning committee, she creates the committee to plan parties with Pam. She likes Jim, but she does not love the film Bridget Jones' diary.
凯伦·菲利佩利会说法语，还会说一点意大利语。她非常喜欢《使命召唤》，她最喜欢的薯片是海盐醋味薯片。在被派对策划委员会踢出去之后，她和帕姆一起创建了派对策划委员会。她喜欢吉姆，但她不喜欢电影《BJ单身日记》。
She gets a brawn panties when Michael offers to buy her something at the mall. She dates Jim for about six months, and in the end, she thinks Pam is kind of a bitch. She's even willing to move to New York if Jim gets a job at corporate. But in the end, when they break up, she takes a job as the regional manager of Utica.
当迈克尔在商场提出给她买东西时，她买了一条勃朗峰内裤。她和吉姆约会了大约六个月，最后，她觉得帕姆有点像个碧池。如果吉姆在总公司找到工作，她甚至愿意搬到纽约。但最后，当他们分手时，她接受了尤蒂卡地区经理的工作。
And while this is not the end of Karen Philippelli, we will not be seeing her for a while. So there you go, Karen Philippelli. Show Bible goodbye. That's all I have for episodes. But we got a general question that made me chuckle. OK. Angela Madeline O wrote in to say,
虽然这并不是凯伦·菲利佩利的终点，但我们有一段时间见不到她了。所以就是这样，凯伦·菲利佩利。剧集圣经式告别。这就是我关于剧集要说的全部内容。但我们收到了一个让我忍俊不禁的普遍问题。好吧。安吉拉·马德琳·O写信来问，
when you guys say we got a letter or we got mail, did you actually get a physical letter, or is that your mom way of saying we got an email? I genuinely want to know. Oh, Madeline, we are such moms. That's an email. That's just an email. But I always think of it as like, well, we got mail.
当你们说“我们收到了一封信”或“我们收到了邮件”时，你们是真的收到了一封实体信，还是那是你们当妈的说法，用来指代我们收到了一笔电子邮件？我真的想知道。哦，马德琳，我们真的是妈妈本妈。那是电子邮件。那只是一封电子邮件。但我总是把它想成，嗯，我们收到信了。
We got mail. Because we're oldies. We are. But I do say we got a letter sometimes. Yeah, because it is a letter. An email letter. Yeah. Yeah, that's mom speak, Madeline.
我们收到信了。因为我们是老派人物。我们确实是。但我有时确实会说我们收到了一笔信。对，因为这也是一封信嘛。电子邮件信。对。对，那是妈妈的专属语言，马德琳。
Yeah. Lady, are you ready for some shout outs? I want shout outs. Several of you have shared with us that you would really like for our insta stories to stay in the highlights on Office Ladies Pod. Because by the time you get to listen to the episode, they're gone.
好了，女士们，你们准备好接受致谢了吗？我想要致谢。你们中的几个人跟我们分享过，你们真的很希望我们的Instagram快拍能留在Office Ladies Pod的精选里。因为等你们去听这集节目的时候，它们已经消失了。
I was like trying to figure out how to do this, because I'm a dinosaur. And I was like, how do I do them every week? How do we do them, Jenna? How do we do them? And then as I was literally trying to figure this out, someone tagged me in a post. And it's from an account called Office Ladies Stories
我当时在想办法怎么弄这个，因为我是个老古董。然后我就想，我怎么每周都弄呢？我们怎么弄呢，珍娜？我们怎么弄呢？然后正当我 literalmente 苦思冥想时，有人在一个帖子@了我。那是一个叫做Office Ladies Stories的账号
on Instagram. So I reached out to Office Ladies Stories on Instagram. And I got in touch with who created it. And I want to give her a shout out. Her name is Azu Garcia. Azu, thank you so much for setting up Office Ladies Insta Story. It's a highlights account.
在Instagram上。所以我联系了Instagram上的Office Ladies Stories。我联系上了它的创作者。我想对她表示感谢。她的名字叫阿苏·加西亚（Azu Garcia）。阿苏，非常感谢你建立Office Ladies快拍精选账号。
Azu shared with me that she recently graduated from the University of Houston with a degree in retailing and consumer science, and that the office got her through long nights of studying. She loves the podcast. And she started the Instagram page because she often listens to the podcast after the stories have left.
阿苏跟我分享说，她最近毕业于休斯顿大学，获得零售和消费科学学位，办公室陪伴她度过了漫长的学习之夜。她非常喜欢这个播客。她创建这个Instagram页面的原因是因为她经常在快拍消失后才听播客。
And she wanted to be able to share them with other people. So Azu, thank you so much. Thank you, because now Angela and I don't have to figure out how to do that. Exactly. We would have never figured it out. I'm pretty sure. I mean, I just didn't know how to maintain it either.
她希望能够与其他粉丝分享。所以阿苏，非常感谢你。谢谢你，因为现在我和安吉拉不用去琢磨怎么弄这个了。没错。我们绝对琢磨不出来。我敢肯定。我是说，我也根本不知道怎么维护它。
That too. Yeah. We're very grateful. Thank you. And lastly, I have wanted to mention this on a revisited a few times. I often quote scenes. I have the dialogue.
也是。对。我们非常感激。谢谢。最后，我在“回溯”里好几次想提到这个。我经常引用一些场景。我有台词。
I like to read it back. I put it in my document, you know? And for episodes that we haven't had the scripts for, there is a website that is amazing. If you want to see the aired version of the office in written word, it's called officequotes.net. It is every word ever said on the show. Oh my gosh.
我喜欢把它读出来。你知道的，我把它放进我的文档里。对于那些我们没有剧本的剧集，有一个网站简直绝了。如果你想看《办公室》播出版本的文字版，它叫officequotes.net。它包含了剧中说过 的每一个字。哦，天哪。
Yes. I find it a great website. And I have used it as we have prepped episode after episode. So thank you. One of my favorite websites is Dunderpedia. And they have a page that is like a Wikipedia page for every single episode of the office.
是的。我觉得这是一个伟大的网站。在我们一集又一集地做准备时，我一直在使用它。所以谢谢它。我最喜欢的网站之一是Dunderpedia。他们有一个页面，就像《办公室》每一集的维基百科页面一样。
And I found something cool. As I was going back to do additional research for season four, they have started adding things to the pages that we have found. Oh, they're updating them. From doing office ladies. Well, that's great. From doing the podcast.
我发现了一件很酷的事。当我回头为第四季做额外研究时，他们已经开始把我们发现的东西添加到页面上了。哦，他们在更新。从做“办公室辣妈”中。嗯，太棒了。从做播客中。
So extra little nuggets that we've gotten from cast members, things that weren't already out there, they are still updating those pages. And that's really cool, too, to look back at a specific episode and see all the fun facts. Yes. Well, there you go. Those are my shout outs.
所以我们从演员那里得到的额外小花絮，那些原本没有公开的东西，他们仍在更新那些页面。这也是一件非常酷的事情，可以回头看某一集并看到所有的趣事。是的。好吧，就是这样。这些就是我的致谢。
I think we revisited it. I think we took a second drink. That was season four revisited. Thank you, Carrie Bennett, for being amazing. Thank you, Creed, for hopping on the phone with me. Thank you, Kate, and Rainn Wilson, and James Apedia. And Bob Thiel for giving us the Pennsylvania Polka rehearsal tape.
我觉得我们温习完了。我觉得我们喝了第二杯。那是第四季回溯。谢谢卡丽·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）的精彩表现。谢谢克里德给我打电话。谢谢凯特、雷恩·威尔逊和詹姆斯·泽佩迪亚。还有鲍勃·蒂尔（Bob Thiel）给我们提供的《宾夕法尼亚波尔卡》排练磁带。
You can find Bob at Bob Thiel Jr. on Instagram, b-o-b-t-h-i-e-l-e-j-r. That was so cool. And you guys, Kate Flannery and Jane Lynch are going to start touring again. Oh, yes. So I'll put in stories where you can find their show dates. They do a fantastic show.
你可以在Instagram上找到鲍勃，账号是鲍勃·蒂尔·小，b-o-b-t-h-i-e-l-e-j-r。太酷了。还有大家，凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）和简·林奇（Jane Lynch）要开始重新巡演了。哦，太棒了。所以我会在快拍里放上你们能找到他们演出日期的信息。他们的演出棒极了。
And you know they have that great Christmas album. I'll put all that in stories. And Carrie Bennett is at Carrie Bennett Costumes. And you can find Creed's tour schedule at creedbratton.com. There you have it, guys, season four. We'll be back next week to keep breaking down season five. Five. Five.
你知道他们有那张棒极了的圣诞专辑。我会把所有这些都放在快拍里。卡丽·贝内特的账号是Carrie Bennett Costumes。你可以在creedbratton.com上找到克里德的巡演日程。好了，各位，第四季就是这样。我们下周回来继续拆解第五季。五。五。
Season five. I'm going to go eat some naughty oats. I'm from St. Louis. Yeah, far too far. I got to use a spoon, not a fork, for my oats. For my naughty oats. My naughty oats. I think we've moved to Wisconsin now.
第五季。我要去吃点淘气燕麦了。我来自圣路易斯。对，差得太远了。我得用勺子，而不是叉子来吃我的燕麦。为了我的淘气燕麦。我的淘气燕麦。我觉得我们现在已经搬到威斯康星州了。
I don't know where we are. I don't know where we are either. We can't do accent. Well, you know what? I have like three I can do. And I don't think Missouri's one. I can't really do any. Oh, well.
我不知道我们在哪儿。我也不知道我们在哪儿。我们学不了口音。好吧，你知道吗？我大概会三个口音。而且我觉得密苏里口音不是其中之一。我其实什么都不会。哦，好吧。
We're going to end the podcast now. We'll see you later. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
我们要结束今天的播客了。我们回头见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听“办公室辣妈”。《办公室辣妈》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍监制。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by creedbratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubicoe）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。想要无广告版本的《办公室辣妈》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。